e
e e
yeah he he mentioned
it okay I'd like to welcome everybody to
today's uh work session which we have on
a number of bills which are are
addressing how we set our formulas up
for uh the regular school funding uh
budget for adequacy and how we may be
funding uh funding special education Aid
um dealing with those those categories
and because they're intertwined as you
all know so what I'm going to do first
before we get into discussing is just uh
advising you as where we're going when
we're meeting on what days so you can
just mark it down on a piece of paper or
in your
computer uh we're we're here today for
this work session so that's this this uh
um Tuesday we're on there is no meeting
on Friday just we have the session on
Thursday where we get the the governor's
presentation and act on our
bills then the following week we will be
meeting on
Tuesday on Tuesday we will be
executing 12 bills and I'll get that
list for you in a few months get a copy
made of those bills which we will be
exacting 12 bills of those 12 10 are
early bills two will be non- early
bills we'll be
starting 10:30 we'll be starting at
10:30 uh there is another meeting with
some of our people to be where they're
doing a similar type thing in finance so
from 10: to 10:30 they will be there and
we'll that this way by not getting subs
for them right now we're we're saving
money for the state and we can start at
10:30 get through those those 12
bills so that's next Tuesday we will not
be
meeting anytime else during that
week so we have of course Monday being a
holiday and meet we meet on Tuesday
Wednesday our room's going to be used by
education policy or Administration and
we won't be meeting that
Friday the following week we will be
that's during the
break uh the February break and we will
be meeting on that
Tuesday and so I'm just advising you
that we will be most likely executing
the bills which we see here on this list
here that we're going to take that
information and pile it into a bill
which we're going to use to move forward
to division two so we're going to try to
whittle that this list down that would
be that week of Tuesday in the last
Tuesday in the month and we'll start in
the morning pardon
me we will be executing yes we will be
executing and we may end up doing more
work what I have to do is that whatever
we're going to send forward to
finance that gives us that last week
within this month to work with LBA and
to work with those who are crafting
amending language to get that done then
the following Tuesday which is the first
Tuesday
in
March we will be taking action on
everything that's an early
bill because we have to have that report
by noon the following day into the
clerk's office on the 5th so we're
closing down that's why we need to use
that that one week day during the
February break very fortunate when I was
on education policy last year we used
every day in here uh so we're fortunate
to have the fewer bills however we have
some very critical bills and we're going
to need some time after we have that
Tuesday meeting during the break to work
with the LBA and work and then come back
with those for action on the following
Tuesday to March
4 the Tuesday of next week is 10:30 we
start are you guys meeting at all on
that uh first or that Tuesday during
break I thought is that
25th so we we got to coordinate we're
trying to coordinate with them uh I
think assume 10:00 for for current
Pardon Me Assume 10:00 a.m. yeah assume
10: a.m. it could slide to that 10:30
but assume 10: a.m. so but it will be on
that Tuesday not later on in that week
okay yeah so just for clarity yeah um
the next three Tuesdays yeah and there
will be exec on all three of them and
other than that the next two weeks we
won't meet it a second day
but I think we should hold on anybody's
calendar the morning of Wednesday the
5th just in case we need it for cleanup
depending on how we fared on Tuesday the
4th that that's basically sop standard
operating procedure if we we need an
amendment made on the 4th uh we have to
do some rushing and then we come in on
the morning of the Fifth Fifth get that
done and we have to have that done by
noon on on on the 5th Wednesday
so that's where we are
today um we're going to start looking at
these bills and um I'm not going to go
down walking through each individual
Bill what we want to do is
start moving
towards a a process a a a overview of
the procedure that we want to follow in
putting together a budget bill there's a
lot of different scenarios we've seen on
this some of doubling the swap some of
working with uh the current type formula
moving things all to the left there's uh
other bills are coming in saying okay
let's talk about fiscal capacity
disparity Aid and let's talk about
relief Aid we see all that and then we
also see within the catastropic side of
reduce it to three and a half to two and
a half um more money at the front side
of that um then that gets into the
discussion of the differentiated Aid to
component of special education so um it
work we're going to put it all on the
table today and try to discuss it then I
would advise either caucus to get
together and try to rope in some angle
that you're after so because we're going
to have to narrow this thing down and we
will with the exact sessions which are
going to
follow so
um in looking at where we are right now
I had made a I'm sure you all have this
but I'm going to hand out to you a
formula which shows if we stay just like
we are
what's it going to look like in FY 26 in
terms of the various columns so I'm
going to hand that out to
you most of you probably have
this I think most everybody has
it but in case you didn't bring it in
case you don't have it on your
computer it's nice to cou one that's
less faint well that has a few pencil
marks on it too and up left hand corner
is a little stain where the coffee fell
on it
once which is typical when I'm touching
things it's a working document yes so
just looking across it we have the of
course the base cost on this formula
then we have three areas of
differentiated Aid then we're walking in
and calculating the cost of an adequate
education and and the swep and you can
see the grants on the right hand side
extraordinary needs Grant we've
discussed that before there is a hold
harmless and that's ratcheting down uh
each bium by
20% and so and we have the issue of the
excess SWAT and this formula that you
see right here does not bring the excess
swap back to the state um that is also
on the table for discussion or where we
need to go with a formula it's remember
the FY 26
budget uh involving the swep excess is
roughly around 28 plus million
do so what I'd like to do is
um start to discuss uh various options
we have on this looking at these
bills and let's take take the ones not
dealing with catastrophic aid for not
first let's go because we've had a
little bit of discussion on that that's
the first that that that's the first one
life
63 uh six first six bills the first six
bills so starting with HB 137 then
relative allocating excess Statewide Ed
education property tax funds for local
school and Municipal
purposes okay
137 okay 137 is a bill that came in from
uh representative cordelli it it's one
where that keeps the swep money and
allows the municipality receiving that
excess swep to use it in any purpose
which is education
oriented that's just quick
summary um let's discuss that where are
we on this concept of swep coming back
into state for redistribution or back to
the
fund or leaving it to the municipality
yes represent spillsbury so just uh to
frame the discussion this is essentially
the diametric opposite of 739 which I
introduced
yesterday um and I do think it's a
fundamental conversation uh for the
committee obviously I've expressed my
opinion that I think that uh our hand
hasn't been forced yet but it's moving
towards the inevitable that we need to
uh call for the exess to be remitted to
the
Dr and and and this is not much
different
than well it's a little bit different
than a bill we had back and I'm looking
at 2011 was HB
337 that's when this all shifted in
2011 and there was a bill put forward
which was used to carry forward the
changes but when it was introduced it
was introduced saying that the
municipalities could keep the excess as
long as it was used for specific two
areas one for building Aid and so if
they were applying for a $3 million
project and they had in their fund $2
million they would only be able to seek
a million bucks um that's just a quick
overview of that and the other option
was to direct the money towards special
education Aid so it would be going after
the old catastrophic Aid they could use
that excess for that that was what that
bill back then then so that's a a little
different than the the one we're looking
at but those are some of the options so
you can either say you keep it and use
it for education purposes as we're doing
or narrow it down or say you don't keep
it and it moves back into the the
formula the state repent
Damon thank you Mr chair good morning
everybody um so two
things the first is just for
clarification the analysis of the bill
references that it's would be the funds
would be available to the local
municipality for school and Municipal
purposes I don't think that's what the
bill says but I just want to clarify
that because Municipal is obviously more
than
school okay
um and
then uh believing that it is in fact not
Municipal that it is for school purposes
in the in the bill language
and as noted in dr's fiscal note it's
just codifying what's happening now I
don't necessarily see that we even need
this even if we agreed with it and I
concur with representative spillsbury
that we're just on the cusp of hearing
from the court that we can't do this
anyway not that I have a crystal ball
but any further discussion on that from
committee members
I think it would be good to hear from
representative fellas um about her bill
which uh takes swept in another
Direction um yeah so I don't remember
the number of it right now but which one
was it it eliminates 527 perhaps yeah
it's the next one down on the list I
believe yeah that's that's I I remember
what it's like um so
essentially it just
to go back to the history of swep that
it was created back in
1999 in response to the Claremont
lawsuit so the state had to convince the
court or show to the court that the
state was making a substantial increase
in the aid that it was providing to the
school districts so it did um changed
the allocation formula and it did send
more more money to school districts but
then it
also just looked at the local tax bill
and declared that a percentage of that
local tax property tax bill for
Education was actually State money as
opposed to local money and it made zero
impact on anybody's property tax bill
because
all the cost of an adequate
education was then and still is set much
lower than any school district could
possibly run on that amount per student
so there's
always additional local money that has
to be raised locally to fund the school
districts every single one of
them so
the the the idea
that well one thing so one one point
that I'd like to make is
that the only substantial source of
Revenue that school districts that towns
municipalities have um including their
school districts the only significant
sort of Revenue they have is the
property tax they're they get get some
money from car registration but you're
not going to get too far with that the
state has no
business
declaring part of their the property tax
to be a state tax and the state should
never be um tap you know tapping that
source of Revenue because the
municipalities need it it's just
inappropriate and in terms of the
argument that's being argued in court
that says it's it's not that you can't
have any
excess that's argument is based on the
fact
that um they're looking at statutes and
and related to Pro to taxes that that's
how you can't have a you couldn't have a
tax that's a state tax and not collect
all of the money that that you say is a
state tax this isn't the the issue is
it's not a state tax at all it's just a
local property tax that they have used
smoke and mirrors to name a state
tax so it's just inappropriate any way
you look at it so what my bill does
because it was that's that tax was
created so it could be an element of the
adequacy Aid formula and reduce the
amount of real
money that the state had to send to the
school districts so my my bill just says
it's it's intended to be Revenue neutral
for the time being it just says that
we're going to keep those numbers in the
adequacy Aid distribution so there's no
cost at this time and then going forward
we can work on that
so um maybe using replacing it with some
other kind of measure that includes
income maybe some other choice so it's
Revenue neutral for now so it's
something that could pass I suppose
without changing the whole
formula brother
discussion I've had my paper I could
have done a better job
go
ahead um without laboring too much could
you just walk us through the bill and
describe the mechanics of
it
um so so we've
got this
handout then when we we got the handout
that just this current adequacy a
formula what this does is it starts at
the left hand side of the page and the
left hand side of the page is is the
actual adequacy Aid the right hand side
of the page is additional Aid that we're
sending to the school districts but
we're I'm only going to talk about the
leand side of the page so using a
formula that says um you know
regular Stu every student is worth at
least
$4,300 and if it's a specialed student
it's worth more more um
and and also in free and reduced just
the basic free and reduced and
additional for students that are English
language Learners you calculate you add
those all together multiply the number
of kids in the category by whatever the
rate is which is on the very um Top
Line you can
see the the first line of numbers that
you see is is the student rate on the
le- hand side of the page the second
line is how much money is being raised
based on
that particular category so at
$4,300 rounded up per student that's
allocating
$648 million in Aid so you take those
and you get over to column
J that's when they're all added up so so
according to this
formula the total cost of an adequate
education is
$819
million
so you should the state should be
sending that amount to the school
districts but it's not because when you
get to column K that's a swept
tax they're subtracting the swept tax
from the 89 $9 million and it brings it
down to under 5 million $500
million so that's how this the
swep is um used in this
formula so my bill just says it's not
it's not a swep tax it's an amount of
money that the uh
local municipality should be
contributing to education
and it
uses just um this it takes one set of
number like the takes probably the
numbers that are you see and it just
uses those going
forward okay does everybody understand
one of the con concerns then how's that
stack up against the prior Court
decisions in terms of the Court yeah
you're saying this is local money not
State
money correct um
yes it is right it's labeling it what it
really is it's always been it's always
always been local money and it's it's
going to label it local
money and and the other thing that's
going on is the state has for the state
collected some of that exess for two or
three years and then since then it
hasn't done that and it's not because
you know it's because there were laws
passed that said don't do that anymore
it was not the original intent then
there then was not the original
intent um when they put together the
formula but then somebody asked the
court and the court said well if it's a
state tax you're going to have to you
know collect the excess and then there
were other bills that passed that
said the local community can keep that
money as long as they spend it on
education and in the last we're talking
about 25 years here it's been changed
you know multiple times so but the state
for the last 20 years the state has not
collected that money and of course it
went to education because as I said
earlier every single School District the
cost of running that school district is
far above what the state has ever
provided so it's always it's money that
the state the local municipalities have
always raised for education so that's
the rationale and the purpose is to just
take that issue off the
table so we can move forward and be
transparent and whatever that the state
is going to send them for Aid will be
real dollars that they actually send for
Aid and we can work on that I would I
personally I think that those numbers
should be based on we should look at
other me issues other ways to measure
the local capacity to um be involved
in um financially supporting education I
think that the municipalities all need
to have some skin in the game I don't
want the state to run the whole
show so we can look at things like um
average aage family income in the
municipality we can look at the value of
the median value of a home we could we
can look at poverty rate you know there
are a lot of ways to do it I'm not going
to say there's only one way yeah that's
getting a little bit into some of the
other discussion we're going to have
today we had a bill last year was it
1583 was that the bill where where we
were also discussing fiscal Capac
capacity Aid and relief Aid and both of
those would go after different sources
of revenue one's based upon equiz
valuation the other one is dealing with
the fnr the uh poverty issues directly
associated with we can that's where we
get this data from as
fnr um and that initially was set up you
didn't get any of that support if you
were less than 12% yeah of your
population
it went on a formula and it had a series
of waterfalls going up which was made it
difficult and that that's going to be
squared away with how we we work our
data here but then at
48% they got Zer the Max and and that
made a significant difference and that
all contributes back in 20111 when we
took that 150 million plus dollars out
of that side of the column and put on
the right hand side and we ended up with
things called stabilization
yeah so and I just say that that you can
go to the department's
website and um if you pick there um tabs
at the top and one of them says I think
it says
data and then look for public
reports and from there it's real easy to
find adequacy Aid and you will find
descriptions of every adequacy Aid
formula going back 20 years a written
description of exactly what it does and
you will see that there were when you go
back even father there were other ways
that um that you know if you call it
fiscal capacity or local contribution
you know essentially the same idea of
what it is there are options for that
and then I'm sure we can come up with
some other options in addition Reon
spillsbury
so I'm going to ask again if you can
walk us through the statutory language
as as opposed to the spreadsheet and and
so you talking about my bill yeah here's
here's the challenge uh and maybe I'm
not as clearheaded as I always am after
many days in a row but um I find this
bill difficult to
read because it amends a whole bunch of
different statutes oh okay and the
result is I read the bill and I'm
confused and I think I'd have to have my
volume of rsas and take it apart one bit
at a time and see what it changes so
could you just simply take us um through
paragraph one paragraph two and tell us
what each one is actually
doing okay so I'd say the whole second
page we don't even need to talk about
that because that just is technical
things if we could let's just start at
the start
yes so that's just the technical thing
so so so where it goes in the formula is
where the the Statewide adequacy 8 is
now those are the numbers what I'm
really asking is to go through the
language of the
bill okay so I'm just saying that what
what is
called adequacy
Statewide education property tax rate
now would be relabeled to be local
contribution and it's just trying to
freeze the amount that's currently proba
it's probably the the numbers that
you're seeing here in K it's taking
those numbers and relabeling them local
contribution and um in terms of doing
the
calculation it
says that money or the cost of providing
an adequate education which would be the
column
J on
here so it can't
be that um
that local contribution is either that
number or it's the total cost of an
adequate calculated cost of an adequate
education let's
see okay in the per in the reason that
it says
that
is because we don't it it and it's in
reality ex any District any
municipality the cost of an adequate
education is going to be more than this
Statewide property tax the only time
that it would not be the case would be
when you have those unincorporated
places
so there would be no excess because the
local it's because it's
the lesser of those
two so this the part that people talk
about being remitted would not exist
because of that
is this
working is that making sense I think
what I like to do is have Mark come on
up and we have and explain how this bill
is different from the one that represent
spillsbury is presenting um I I think
they're both trying to use the swep
money to bring over and support ad
adequacy but can you go further please
mark I I have my computer charging out
back so I don't have the bill in front
of me but um a representative fellow's
bill um essentially reclassified swept
as a local contribution yeah um the
mechanics of it is is essentially
freezes swept for a moment in time so
swept is that 363 Milli million
allocation throughout all 245 towns and
so that becomes a frozen Benchmark that
is your swept um when we are um uh
calculating how much and remember we do
state cash so it's cost of inadequate
education minus
swept State cash that's the number
that's how we determine how much we're
going to pay out
um so it freezes that 363 million Al
allocation for a moment in time and then
we're going to continue to do the cost
of inadequate education calculation and
for most communities as representative
fellow said um the cost of inadequate
education is going to be greater than
whatever your portion of the 363 million
swept is and then we will cut you a
check per usual what this bill does is
is take that swep number says it is not
State money it is a local contribution
and so we'll now measure you up against
your local contribution and um whatever
your local contribution is that your
allocation of that 363 million um uh um
we'll measure you up against that if
you're over it we'll cut you a check
what this does for the uh approximate 43
excess swep towns is it's choose the
lesser of the two so either your
allocation of the 363 million or your
cost of in adequate education and for
the ex swept towns when we do that
calculation we would determine that The
Benchmark we measure you up against is
not going to be your portion of the
swept it's going to be the cost of an
adequate education and therefore it
eliminates excess swept by saying um by
not by saying the calculation is going
to be the lesser of the two either the
cost of an adequate education or swept
and so swept is excess swept is when
swept is higher than the cost of an
adequate education but we're now saying
the lesser of the two so therefore
um uh uh we pay you whatever the cost
and adequate education is or you're
that's the state funding you receive so
there's no excess swept which is excess
State funding uh above and above above
and beyond the cost of an adequate
education I don't know if that helped
it's pretty it's a it's a little pretty
techy it's like going around around
circles here
but uh representative Damon
we yeah in in the one just above two 137
and I believe representative spillsbury
um I'm not was that was that basically
just the Rand decision as the Superior
Court determined just a a a straight A
straight implementation of that is that
your bill exactly just remit the excess
and if if if that bill was implemented
um $28 million Coes into the education
trust fund is remitted to the state um
no other changes happen um that $28
million would be Revenue available for
you to
access Damon did you have a question or
thank you input so now I have
two
so the LA thank you for helping us the
last thing you just said that the 28
million which is the total amount of
swep M excess swep yep thank you in
representative spilsbury's bill would go
to the state so
I'm trying to figure out that is then
like the revenue has just moved right it
hasn't changed so that uh oh oh good
yeah good point um it's actually the way
to think about it on our financial
statements is the revenue has always
been collected on paper through a
journal entry in our Acer um but the
actual thing that is changing is we
don't let them keep it so therefore it's
a almost like a 28 million less um
expense because now they do not get to
keep excess swept therefore we're not
giving them $28 million so that's
actually the proper way to think about
the financial transaction um the 28 all
363 million is currently always showing
up in our financial statements but if if
representative spillsbury were
implemented um 28 million less would go
out and therefore you'd have 28 million
in the bank by allowing these
municipalities to keep the ex swep is
that in contradiction to the Claremont
decisions um that
uh thean Cas so I definitely can't I
definitely can't determine that but that
those are uh um uh swept was implemented
after the Claremont decision so I I
can't okay so in conflict with well what
would be in conflict with Rand then yeah
Rand the Rand Superior Court decision
said no excess
weap represent fellows and then back and
that rep
McGuire so so I I just wanted to to say
that for the for the municipalities that
would remit any back to the state then
they have
to that's that's kind of like a cost to
them because they're going to have to
fill in that suppose that they had to
send back um $2 million I most of them
are not that high but if they have to
send $2 million back to the state
they are going to have to raise $2
million more
because as I said all all school
districts um need more than the than the
state cost of in education to
operate so that's you know just to be
clear that you know that's going to cost
them s significant more more money
yeah clarify that U um the the $28
Million number those are communities
that um U there's some unincorporated
communities in there that do not have ch
uh students that they educate but most
of those communities have students that
they educate in school districts that
they either operate or send students to
um tuition out um so that $28 million
for those 43 communities um if they did
not decrease their budget found another
source of Revenue then their taxes would
go up by 28 million so there that's the
the way to think about
that
yes sorry to jump into the queue but
just to clarify so what I was trying to
drive at is whether your bill HB 527
simply
recharacterize swept in a way that uh
you know tries to ameliorate this this
constitutional issue or does it actually
result in the change or shifting of any
funds in any
direction um it it does address
the
um that the grand decision that we're
looking at it has zero impact on the
amount of real money that the state
sends to any
town and I and i' also think that we
need to keep in mind you know we we
don't know what kind of Court ruling is
going to come down on the CL on the
conal case we don't we don't know but if
you want to assume that
this the Supreme Court is going to say
that the state has to pay more than
$4,000 $300 per student for an adequate
education then when the when the C if if
that suppose it doubled
then that measurement of the excess will
change because there will be less excess
because the cost of inadequate educ tion
is going to be
higher
so okay
um go ahead on on this one then we're
going to try and move on a little bit
thank
you would you be so kind as to revisit
your
remarks um in regards to the 43x or so
excess swep towns and just again walk
through that example of the impact of
527 yep gladly um so in hypothetical say
we have an EXs web Community um um uh
representative fellow's uh bill just to
back up a little bit representative
fellow's Bill essentially does no
nothing financially different for school
districts it just changes the labeling
from uh um to local contribution um the
only change you would see if
representative fellow's bills was
implemented is you would see a change in
our acur and how financially report
state aid to school districts um and you
would see a difference in financial
reports submitted to the state those
would be the changes you would see if
representative fellows was implemented
now we're talking about representative
spillsbury bill um to essentially
Implement Rand as the Superior Court
decided it um to go through that example
say you have a school district that has
a $2 million
budget they receive $1 million in local
funding uh local education taxes and
then $1 million in swept and they
receive zero State cash cash just in
this hypothetical their excess swept
community so they have a million doll
swept Revenue coming in a million doll
local Leed Revenue coming in they have
to fund their $2 million budget let's
say that 1 million swept let's say
500,000 is
excess so what would happen at that
moment in time if Rand was implemented
the bill was implemented uh
representative spillsbury bills was
implemented they would continue they
would have to continue to pay a million
and swept regard uh that would not
change they would pay a million dollar
and swept what would change is they
would not keep the excess swept to
500k so they would have to send that to
the state so now that 500k is not
funding their school so now they're
paying a million dollars in swept taxes
but they only have 500k for their
revenue um they pre pre- bill um
pre-implementation they were paying a
million local lead now they're going to
pay 5 1.5 million in local lead plus the
million swept so the net impact of the
taxpayer is they lost their excess swept
they're paying 500k and now they funded
their school at 2 million but they lost
their excess swept so the taxpayer um
was paying that anyways but the taxpayer
decided to use that U fill that budget
Hole by increasing local taxes
okay further disc represent McGuire
thank you and Mr chairman I I believe
it's a house rule that you can only
drink water in a committee room not
coffee or
whatever yeah and I drink coffee because
I stay awake I understand and and it's
it's a it's a water-based product it's a
it's a rule that's honored in the in the
breach I guess anyways okay quick
question and I'm sorry sorry
still don't have my voice but
anyway do you know what year the 363
million came
in represent fellows might know I think
it's the mid 2000 we do have a historian
here uh that was here when we went
through it come you come on up for a
second and maybe you can help us answer
that introduce yourself to everybody
I've seen you many many times at our
finance
meetings and Doug Hall hi Mark
um the 30 the first year 1999 swep was
set at
$660 that was the tax rate that was 1999
couple years later it was
$5.80 then it was $4 and I don't have it
in front of me but I think it was
$462 and then the next change was to say
it'll that Dr should raise the same
amount as the prior year the the rate
was taken out and that was 363 million
and then after that the law was changed
to say 363
million
until two years ago when it was changed
to 263 million for one year and then
back up to
363 so this started in 1999 at $66
60 and has been I would guess it's
probably 12 years that it's been 363
million with the exception of the one
year when it went down to
263 thank you very much thank you um all
right that that's enough thank
you further discussion on on the swep
side here
yes can you just inform us excuse me
what the lowest and the highest swept
rates are per town to result in that
363 oh I'm
sorry can you tell us the lowest and the
highest so the range of swept rates per
town to result in that 363 so so this is
a um the answer to that is everyone pays
the same rate um that's not the rate you
see on your tax bill because the rate on
your tax bill is against an the assessed
property of your town that's not
equalized so each town has different
assessing practices so you'll see
deviations on your tax bill your swep
tax bill might be higher than your
neighbors in another town um um but when
we set the when the swept is set it's
the 300 whatever the rate needs to be
for every single Community to raise the
363 it's essentially one rate it's an
equalized rate and so it's 112 uh for uh
fiscal year 26 it's going to be 1 12 per
th000 yes repent fellow
um yes on this issue um what I
distributed when I I testified on my
bill was I took part of the equalized
property values and the tax rates and
just showed them just the columns or the
equalized rates and on here you can see
that the rates are not you know equal
they're they go up and down there
there's quite a good range on these and
that's because you can't really
the the idea of equalized valuation is
more a concept than something you can
actually achieve because what what Dr
does and I'm I don't know if we have a
Dr person here is they look at equalized
valuations they first they look at at
the assessed values of properties in
every town and then they compare those
assess the
values to the sales value on on
properties that sold during the past
year and they say whatever that ratio is
if if the the average sale price was 20%
higher than the appraised price for the
all those properties then they kind of
blanket say the equalized valuation of
all similar properties when up 20% so
that's how they get the equalized values
so they take the equalized values from
about 3 years ahead
of when they actually
apply are actually applied to the tax
bills so you're using three-year-old
equalized
valuations when you get your tax bill
because and because property values have
shifted and it's not even across the
shift was not even across all the
municipalities in the state that's why
you see equalized values on this report
which are different from town to
town so what you're getting for the the
taxation really
isn't it
um I don't know what to call it it's not
very accurate there's a lot of there's a
lot of margin of error in every single
person's property tax bill that happens
at the local level but at least they get
reassessed they do a full revaluation
every five years when you try to take
this up to the state level you're not
going to have everybody getting
revalued on the same cycle so one town
your Town's going to get valued one year
and you know the next person um they
they their value is 2 years old and the
next person the next town their value is
three years old and so that's why you're
not getting a consistent rate so any
attempt to try to do a state equalized
tax rate is not it's not going to be
very F accurate at all so and the other
thing that's going to happen is if this
is really a state tax then they need to
collect they need to get the money that
people actually pay in their their tax
and we know that not everybody pays
their property tax so who's going to
fill the Gap in the middle that's going
to be the municipalities again it's not
as you know the state should only get
the money that's actually paid and then
they should also be reimbursing the town
for being their agent to collect it it's
very becomes very complicated when you
try to scale it up above the single
municipality level property
taxes this questions for Mark um this
may reveal a simplistic uh understanding
but would it be correct theoretically at
least that if all towns were mandated to
rvalue on the exact same fiveyear cycle
so they I mean I don't know what the
Manpower would be for the contractors
and so on but but but but if every town
revalued in the same year does that
completely uh uh Wipe Out the equalized
value valuation requirement yeah if if
there was some sort of consistent
standardized process um to for everyone
to assess in the same manner um
you you could you could work towards
getting rid of the equalization process
um uh so just capture that caveat um I
guess what I'm asking is is the timing
by year the only variable or is there
another variable when you just said the
manner in which they
assess um I I can't speak to that I'm
not a I'm not a I'll talk in a little
bit on this because we just went through
this in my community and the
re-evaluation occurred to the
Residential Properties not the
commercial properties for one it was
done off cycle after three years rather
than going the fiveyear cycle um so
there there that creates a problem in
itself if you're going going to do this
reassessment when the market values are
up on top of us high and that's when
we're going to do the reassessment
rather than waiting maybe that's going
to go down a little bit here and that
impacts how our formula you know what
type of dollars you're going to receive
in the formula to a degree I've talked
to you about that before but um there
are a number of variables there that we
should be aware
of go ahead yeah just just um um as far
as the equalization process um
definitely Dr can speak to that as far
as uh how it works and how they what
methodology they use in towns um the
equalization process just to walk
through the timeline cuz the timeline
does create um swept is lagged and
there's a reason for why it's lagged so
just to walk through the timeline um in
the fall of
24 Town assessors sent in about 500
towns um or 245 towns uh uh uh sent in
their property values it's called the
ms1 form they sent that into Dr Dr then
took that data and they went through
their Equalization process of bringing
everyone up to market value and they
didn't publish that um uh some
communities might challenge it so they
might not trust the equalization or they
get toe process uh before the
equalization process is complete um so
they could challenge it um so as that
Equalization process is going it takes
about nine months to complete so you
collect the data in the fall of 24 um or
actually I'll use 20 uh 23 September 23
they collected it uh published it in the
spring of for spring summer of 24 then
we use that data so it's collected in
fiscal year 24 in fiscal year 25 to
estimate what your swept is going to be
in fiscal year 26 so just talking about
using data from fiscal year 24 we're
using it to forast you're swept that
you're going to pay in fiscal year 26 so
that's a two-year lag and the reason why
one of the year is the equalization
process takes about a year for it to go
through the process and people can
challenge it Etc that takes about a year
and then the reason why we also forast
it out in the future which there are
some bills to think about considering
not forecasting it out in the future is
because now you have an accurate swept
number that you can build your school
budget off of and also um uh Finance has
an accurate adequacy estimate we can
build adequacy off of um so having that
one year lagin swept is uh makes
budgeting more accurate um and then one
year just is inherent because the
equalization process does take some time
to complete so that's why swept has a a
pretty substant two-year lag on it
further discussion here yes represent so
just on um comment on the possibility
that you would want to do a reevaluation
of the entire state in in a single all
all on the same year the people who do
these um valuations these appraisers
they have to be licensed to do this and
there are only so many of them and the
5e cyc I assume a lot of them are going
you know the these this these companies
that do the assessment they do one town
one year another town the next year you
wouldn't I don't know how you'd um you
you need about five times as many that
that was a hypothetical type discussion
that represent I was I was acknowledging
that the contractors would be spread
thin yeah yeah yeah to get a point
across so with the swep um that's one
area where there is revenue available if
we have to be looking at Revenue to
bring in and support the
formula
um I do have a sheet here which I'd like
to pass out to everybody so we can get
some of the discussion going right
across the board on the
formula me yes represent K thank you Mr
chairman I'd like to um tap into
something that I've heard representative
fellows mentioned several times about
our swep and the taxpayers who are not
paying their bills and the
municipalities being on the hook the
correct me if I'm wrong in this the way
I understand it today is that our
municipalities are already on the hook
because they have to pay that over to
the school regardless of whether they
collect it or not um so I'm a little
confused as to you using that reference
with it going to the state being any
different than what we're already
experiencing
today when when the town isn't
collecting that swep tax
so uh you know this is revenue issue but
I know what towns do they have something
that's called the overlay because they
know that that not everybody pays their
tax bills so so they make the assessment
you know two or three or 4% higher than
it needs to be to fund the budget but
it's different when it's your town and
it's your neighbor that can't pay his
taxes and eventually what will happen is
they might take that property for non-
tax
payment as opposed
to sending it to you know sending it to
the state the other thing it's really
complicated because some people pay
their taxes late you know sometimes they
pay half their
taxes why
would it's just seems to me like you
know the municipality is giving a giving
away money to the state
that that was
Municipal money it was that overlay
money that they were using to so isn't
that what they're already doing right
now when they send it over to the school
so instead of sending that that money
over to the school district they're
going to be sending it to the state so
isn't it the same thing it's just
redirecting who's receiving it I would
say it's not the same thing because it's
their budget you know it's their budget
it's the town's budget paying for
services for people in the town which is
different than paying you know giving
the money to be used in somebody else's
town or to the
state okay I'd like to go ahead and look
at this form and bring up another side
discussion here um a formula working
left to right has from the base costs
right through to the extraordinary needs
Grant on the right hand side money is
targeted on the right hand side of the
formula they're grants for
specific purpose the money on the left
hand side of our formula is
money which is generated based upon what
we establish as a base cost and those
areas of differentiated Aid which go to
the municipality the district and
they're not targeted necessarily to a
specific task like English language
Learners even though there may be
funding within that differentiated Aid
that does not have to be used in that
direction so in looking at the sheet
that you have
here and jumping down because you don't
have the information on on one through
four that's been presented but and
identifies for this this is just a
concept looking at the right hand side
there is money through the extraordinary
needs
Grant which amounts to
$14.9
million then we also have a column which
we call hold Harless which in the
fy2 that we're working right now was $59
9 million it ratchets down over the next
10 years if you add the 184. n and the
59.1 together you come up to $244
million on the right hand
side which is coming from the
state should that be moved to the
leftand side and put underneath a
category like physcal capacity where we
once had some of that before or putting
it underneath relief Aid of some kind
based upon on separate criteria maybe
criteria on on income and one on on
property values uh this is a concept
that some are are talking about and then
you would have also that hold harmless
if you brought that in you would have
another $28.6 million you could add into
that total
244 million doll and spreading that over
my question now to Mark is but if we
move that everything from the right to
the
left what kind of holes would we have
for those property poort towns would
would there still be because when when
you add money into the leftand side
you're also adding it on to every town
is going to get this money in in fact
some of the targeted money has been
targeted specifically to those
towns haven't run a spreadsheet doing
that exercise but to Move It from the
right side to the left side yeah should
have no impact um
uh uh if one of
these um one of the things we do on the
right side of the formula is we
basically look if your excess swept if
you're excess swept you don't get it um
so there could be some netting against
excess swept um so it could lower the
amount of excess swept but a lot of
excess swept communities would not be
targeted
um uh to begin with so um I think with
um um like relief Aid if relief Aid was
reenacted um some of that if you say you
wanted to take 17 million in relief Aid
and move it from right side to left side
some of that would net against excess
swept so it wouldn't truly distribute 17
million that would be the only impact
but basically moving from right side to
left side you've financially
done no no no significant impact
financially and how the distribution is
done what you've done is you've recoded
something from additional Aid
essentially to constitutional Aid that
is the the major impact that you would
see if that was enacted you are moving
the players on that chess board around a
little bit so now that when it comes to
what what is the state contributing
towards the cost of a student the the
price might go from $5,000 or whatever
we're doing right now to close to $7,000
per pupil that that's correct that would
be um you would uh say you enacted this
the way a judge might see this would um
all of it would be on the table to be
reviewed by a judge um currently in the
litigation we have conal we have Rand we
have Rand has multiple parts to it conal
just looked at base adequacy a so they
just looked at that 4,000 number um and
they did not look at differential Aid
that was what conal looked at so
narrowly scoped to look at that um uh
the ran trial which is ongoing and has
uh uh uh Superior Court has not fully
decid made a decision on that it's been
broken up into pieces but we just had a
ran Rand a Rand part of the ran trial
this fall was to look at is the um fnr
and special education Aid is that
adequate because that's on the left side
and can be constitutionally challenged
um no
one the litigation is not looking at
extraordinary needs Grant in any
meaningful way the litigation is not
looking at the hold harmless Grant in
any meaningful way however if you were
to take it from the right side to the
left side um that that more likely to
get involved into the litigation instead
of just being looking at base and
differential Aid that's
correct thank than you any further
comments on on that possible you know
way of looking at Distributing the
dollars yes repr yes um I think that
almost anything we want to look at that
we should also have a column that shows
us the per pupil amount that the
municipality is getting because we just
see this is just concept right here I
don't think there is a spreadsheet doing
this right now oh okay so we're just
looking at this concept other words
I I think that it can be justified uh
there there's two philosophies on how
you establish what the cost of a child
is going to be you can do it by the
inputs what are those resources or
components that are necessary to provide
the child the opportunity for an
adequate education or you can look at
the end result on the right hand side
this is the amount of money that we're
spending for an adequate education and
we know that our achievement scores are
very high compared to the rest of the
country so must be doing something
correct so if you divide that you can
find out here's the average cost we're
spending so that's what we have to have
it um I'm a Believer though that we need
to have in a base inputs what are those
inputs what is the ratio to teacher in
the classro of student to teacher that's
the input way of doing it and that's the
way I believe the 2008 study that came
out of the esbrook study uh identified
the formula to be so I I I I I I think
that if we're going to move into it and
I I talked to uh represent luno about
his plan which is the foundation formula
which it's very complicated to say the
least uh but it has it's has some
different principles it's working upon
and I I I that they're worth very worthy
of our looking at And discussing but to
accomplish that in the short time we
have to unload a bill by Mark March 6 I
don't know I haven't even seen a
spreadsheet on yet so we may have to be
carrying our discussion forward and
looking at something more transitional
to get us to where we need to get moving
in that direction and complying as much
as we can yes I do represent
Burton I'm trying to figured all this
out that um it looks like what you're
suggesting just as the cya move to move
money over from the right side to the
left side to make it look like a I don't
think I you know you're using some
military jargon there and I I don't see
it that way uh I see it that the state
is putting money into the pot right now
it's putting in the pot but that's not
being
counted with because of this formula
that we
have can one more question comment um
you keep referring to the fact we have a
really good education system but it's
turned out it's it's a it's that level
of Excellence can't be
supported because we're hearing from the
towns now that they need more money even
had a a bill to um to to lower the
standards recently so so the problem is
not the quality of education but it's
how we whether we can sustain the level
of support we're getting from the state
now well we're getting off onto another
topic here but I would I would entered
into that discussion there are a lot of
non-dollar variables which contribute to
learning aspiration of the community
attitude of those in the building
leadership in the building uh emphasis
on what your curriculum looks like and
how you're imparting that to
students uh I I can recall when I went
to school I I I was brought up in Canada
and I 25 28 30 kids in my classroom and
we all learned why do we learn well I
had a teacher that was from Scotland and
you didn't dare look left or right other
than to her you didn't make play games
and but now we have a society is
changing we have a lot of other
variables we have to consider but I
don't think it's all going to be
answered this is my gut I'm talking as
Rick lad now yes I understand there is
Need for dollars to facilitate that but
there are other other variables which
come into I can show you school
districts that have high
performance but they are not receiving
any additional dollars why is that I can
go to the little blue skull up in Landa
small school it's an older looking
building K through three they're doing a
great job is it Community
involvement uh so those variables we
need to consider quick quick note Canada
in Canada the federal government pays
for all special
education I was talking back in
1955 perap spillsbury
so it's a relatively new entrance into
this discussion in the last couple of
years I found the right side left side
to be pretty perplexing because as a
math matter it doesn't seem to make any
difference um and I think that's what
Mark was telling us a few minutes ago so
what difference does it make if it makes
no difference in the math I I suppose
that it's a messaging um difference I
suppose that it's
potentially in light of the Court's
precedence a legal constitutional
difference so if if you if you want to
pay strong attention and be guided by
the the Court's presidents then the
purpose of those entries on the left
side is to say this is what the
legislature deems to be the cost of
inadequate
education this is what we're going to
support and I think that that leads us
to the fundamental flaw in the conval
decision the conval decision by looking
exclusively at base adequacy has
stripped it down to a figure that has to
be provided uh uniformly to every
student throughout every District uh and
and that's that's I won't say that it's
pointless but it misses so much of the
point and it deprives the legislature of
its Duty and opportunity to gauge other
variables so whether those variables are
free and reduced as a proxy for poverty
Early Learning whether you enter back
into the left side uh uh capacity to pay
uh in terms of local property values uh
you know that's essentially what I think
we're we you know our own legislative
precedent asks us to do to put into the
left side what we think is fairly
characterized as a cost of adequate
education and frankly if we do
that then I think and we do that
responsibly I think that's the primary
rebuttal to the argument in the court
that a
single base adequacy
is the answer to a constitutional
obligation um so I guess I would to try
and bring that back to your
point I would weigh the question whether
a particular form of Aid goes to the
left or the right if we're even making
that
distinction um based on that question of
what constitutes the base adequacy
versus what helps districts pay it
I'll be right back sure representative
buron um I just read the con Bell
decision and the judge covers that he
said it would be impossible to do an ad
adequacy uh analysis that accounts for
all the different budgets in the in the
state so he picked on the conservative
side he's he very clear about that that
his numbers are very conservative and
then he goes through every single
category and decides what the average
should be and he only deals with the
cost side he doesn't deal with the
revenue side in in that in that in that
decision the other thing I'd like to add
if I could say one more
thing I was with Doug Hall when we both
had brown hair and
uh and I I was on the augenblick
committee that applied the form formul
that worked the Supreme Court found it
it would work as I recall done remember
it went to the it passed the house it
went to the Senate it passed the Senate
it went into Senate Finance I think that
bill House Bill four I believe it was
wasn't it would you allow Doug to
describe that process because it worked
the court liked it the legislature
passed it do you care to come forward
again
I well I've I've saved you the problem
because I've been into leg even within
the lifespan of people in the room we
can call it ancient
history I but I want to say I I have the
research is being done across the street
right now on how that that whole process
went um and I've got the research people
doing it because um it's the only time
we had a a formula in place to fund
education that the Supreme Court
actually liked and if if if the they if
they put 8% of the cost you can't say
that representative fellas would you
make a comment well I'm not a lawyer but
you can't say that that the court liked
it liked what we did because the court
can only say something when someone
brings a case to the court and then so
you can it can be all wrong for a long
time and you don't get a Court ruling
until somebody takes it to the court
well so and I'm not a lawyer okay I
apologize you're you're absolutely
correct but what we can do in the
legislature is send a a proposal to the
Supreme Court for an advisory
opinion and we did that and it came back
they advised us that that formula would
would satis safy the school funding
issue in the state so that's why we we
wouldn't have brought it forward to the
for a vote in the house which passed it
or the Senate would passed it if if we
hadn't had that in our hand and I'm
getting a copy from the
archives um I have some questions to POS
but before I do any further
comment okay so right side left side
upside downside um I I I do think that
one thing that's uh missing from the
formula it's it's here in a way but it's
not
here in in a way that I think is
entirely
satisfactory and that is the
extraordinary needs Grant so we've had
fiscal capacity disparity a these are
all variations on a theme but the point
being to uh provide a figure that's
based on equalized valuation and uh and
students
and uh the senate in the last term took
1583 and and changed it and worked it
into
hb2 uh so that there is a calculation in
the extraordinary needs Grant that's
based on the number of students who
qualify for free and reduced but I think
it also differs considerably in a number
of other ways in terms of the way it
bracketed
thresholds um and uh Mark I'm wondering
whether we can get current numbers based
on the formulation that the house passed
uh two years ago in 15 or was it last
year in
1583 yeah we could run the same exact
language um through the um the modern
data set uh the issue you would have is
it' probably come out with less money um
because property values have gone up
since last year um that would be the
only change you would you would see but
we could run could run that number I do
think it would be interesting to see
where the current numbers would lie
relative to the extraordinary needs
Grant figures we already have okay so
any any comment on that can you Ju Just
explain which bill is that a
2024 bill or 1583 was a 2024 Bill and so
when uh a year ago when there was a
special
subcommittee um two bills were reported
out then approved by the full committee
approved by the house and died in the
Senate largely because it was an
off-budget year I'd like to see what
frankly both of those bills would look
like here one year later so I'd also
like to see when you do that to put put
a column that shows per
pupil um at the end what they end up
with for a grant sounds good thank you a
grant that's the real money yeah good
suggestion now another question uh
anybody else want
to
okay I don't know whether where this
really leaves the districts on a net
basis but I've I've really questioned
why the um special education is one of
the categories of uh of
adequacy and we've got about $69 million
more or less uh going to the districts
in the form of of a single allowance per
student so tracking representative
fellow's thoughts that's uh
no
$2,184 and uh we've had conversation uh
with several bills about
uh the shortfalls of having one figure
and uh whether there should be category
a b and c whether there should be 13
different types of special ed uh broken
out uh whether this leads to
stigmatization and so on and so forth
and uh I raised the question when we
were having a work session a week ago on
special ed what if we took all the money
that we currently allocate to special ed
and maybe more um a year ago we were we
passed out a bill that had an extra 35
Mill million for for special ed and uh
revamp the
um the cat Aid so that all the money
we're putting into special Aid is
reformulated into something that's
essentially like an insurance product
that lowers the Threshold at which the
state contributes from three and a half
down to something considerably lower say
hypothetically two um so this the the
the districts would be responsible for
their own special Aid costs up to that
level but then maybe the state kicks in
at 50% or these are hypothetical figures
all you know X Y and Z
variables uh
so is
there is there support for doing
something like that and what are the
implications if we if we dramatically
enhance uh that insurance product can we
then in turn
rationalize uh taking the special Aid
base allowance out of the adequacy
formula um I think that's an important
discussion that's part of this big
picture of what the formula looks
like representative fellas so um if let
me see if I understand what you're
proposing so we could take we have
special ed Aid formerly known as
catastrophic we have that pot of money
and then we'll take
the 69
um
million out out of the adequacy aid and
put it in the same pot with the
catastropic and then decide how we want
to sort it out and then maybe then we
can justify another 35 million on top of
that which is what we were prepared last
year to uh to add to the the pool and
that and that will be adequate special
ed
Aid okay because it counts I mean if the
court wants to know do we fund adequate
education we have this adequate
distribution and then we have our we'll
have our adequate special Aid special ed
distribution yes yeah whether you car
characterizes it as adequacy or adequate
Aid or not um what I'm what I'm really
looking at is how do we better protect
the
districts from the kind of expenses that
are unanticipated unreserved and often
unbudgeted that they find with uh and so
we would be moving away if we did this
we would be moving away from a single
figure allowance regardless of the
actual needs or the actual costs of
individual students and we would moving
we would be moving over to a format
where the state is
receiving specific uh submission from
the districts about their actual costs
and providing dramatically more State
assistance in those reimbursement of
those actual costs and by the way I
think one of the purely incidental point
one of the criticisms of our cadid is
that uh it only comes back at the end of
a year in the form of reimbursement but
we could we could r rejigger that where
the there was uh you know an advance
based on the prior year and a
Reconciliation at the end of the year
so that's a that's a big mouthful I've
just thrown out there on the table I I I
don't I don't think that the fact that
it's a year delay is a problem okay
because it's it's kind of
continual and um these costs even you're
saying you're you're being reimbursed
for last year's expenses in time to use
those funds for the current year so you
might well you might need to be careful
about the transition year make sure that
they're not so it's a rolling a Rolling
Cash Flow yeah
so the and to and actually even those
high cost students generally they do
budget for them so they they know about
that part I just want to
clarify
that um what they're doing for
catastroph catastrophic Aid right now
they're looking at every single invoice
to make sure that it was um allow an
allowable cost so but there are a lot of
special ed expenditures that are the PA
professional in the room there's um they
have specialed teachers and the expense
of writing the IEP so I think there
needs to be some things that just go
that don't need the same level of
scrutiny they only above the level of
scrutiny we were hearing a couple weeks
ago that Arkansas they uh they audit one
out of every
um as special ed student cases so it
could be labor intensive but um but if
obviously if we were to bring
theoretically if we were going to bring
the threshold down from three and a half
times actual cost to two times um the
average cost uh the universe of of
students and claims would expand
substantially repres
Burton did you have
something I tried to find the Rand
decision on my desk this morning among
the stuff to St but I believe that in
that correct me if I'm wrong didn't
didn't uh the judge say some of the
costs would go into the left side and
the rest would go on the right
side not familiar with any um statement
like
that I I I wish I had the the case with
me but is there anybody in the room who
can clarify that
question yes Mr Hall could you step up
to the
mic well oh I'm
no right I'm talking about
the I'm talking about the um what he's
reviewing from the lower court now I I
think he the lower court may have done
that separated the some of the special
ed costs and put it on the left side and
the rest on the right
side during the trial so um um Doug is
right uh the conval has gone through the
superior court so there's a decision out
now it's in the Supreme Court so there's
no decision out of the Supreme Court the
Rand excess swept has gone through the
superior court is now in the Supreme
Court so there's there's statements from
judges on that um during the trial
during the litigation left side right
side was brought up but the judge has
not made any sort of statement or
opinion um uh uh uh relative to left
side right side there was no there was
no conversation really of right side and
the conell decision that I'm yeah conell
did not consider right side um in the
judge's order um a judge R is going to
have another order because there's Rand
now there's a the Rand decision is now
looking at um special education
differential Aid the thing you're just
discussing so uh judge ruol in that
order could um uh the superior court
order could could make some comment
about left side right side but um I'm
not familiar with any comment made about
that and not that anyone's interested in
history but I would point out that in
84 855 the sunset committee uh deleted
the
um special education they were not going
to reauthorize it at all we'd be the
only state in the Union that did that so
that's when I and Betty joea you may
remember um we wrote the special ed law
because Governor sonunu John sonunu was
adamant that that was wrong and Sen
speaker Tucker was wrong from Plymouth
and we rewrote that bill rewrote the
program over a year that coincided Ed
with the um the case where the Laconia
state hospital had to close down and we
were figuring out how to deal with many
of the residents coming out because they
went into special education theyve been
Warehouse prior to that I met some of
them and their parents and and special
ed you're sort of not on your
head uh and so that's some of the
history you should know uh that it was
was a bipartisan group group that
reconstituted special ed because it's so
important to so many families in our in
our
state representative
bricky um so getting back to what you
said about
um it might be a burden on um on the doe
or on their staff yesterday I was amazed
when and of course I can't think of her
name now from the state said the special
ed um Caitlyn when Caitlyn said she only
has
a025 FTE staff member and in
the it wasn't Caitlyn it Melissa Melissa
thank you that's okay um at least you
had a name I didn't even have one um so
and she has to hire part- timers in June
so that might
be a real burden
on financial bur fair fair to say there
would be an administrative requirement
yes
agreed yes representative peoples thank
you representa spillsbury one of the
things that came out of yesterday's
testimony that I thought was very
enlightening was the fact that there was
no quantitative way of measuring
anything the IEPs are written narrative
um we're delivering Services we get an
invoice
in it says speech therapy speech therapy
invoice we pay it so we don't know
whether we have one quantity or two
quantities or five quantities of it and
whether that bill is rational based on
that students um IEP or other
educational programs that he's in I
think no matter what we do we need to
come up with a way and it may add some
labor at the doe and maybe even at the
local level but there should be a way to
quantify what we're delivering for
services versus what we're paying and it
might come down to like every I has a
fiscal note that says this is what we're
delivering we're going to give them five
units of speech uh they have a pair of
professional whatever and when that
invoice comes in we have a way of
rationalizing what we're going to cut a
check to them and provide some
transparency and some accountability
into that process not that I'm saying
there's a problem
but we do need a way to going forward as
we work through these formulas in the
future understand what those costs
really represent and how they impact um
the Educational
Funding thank so internal cost
accounting principles that uh are used
routinely in business don't always find
their way into government services yes
representative Burton when we were
writing the special ed law in New
Hampshire I I chaired the subcommittee
on
IEPs and pretty soon I realized the
whole people in the in the workshop
rooms were
lawyers uh and and that the parents were
getting clobbered uh when they went into
the IP meetings because often the school
districts come in and say any cost is
too great and the parents come in saying
no cost is too great for my kid and any
parent in here knows that's probably
where you'd be um there is no direct
answer to your question representative
it's a matter of judgment and so to elay
some of that I did sponsor on a trial
basis mediation on IEPs and that was
suggested by the doe I do you remember
that
Doug uh and and that gave that moved
that the discussion offline to take some
of the emotion out of it um I must say
that special education and I I had
because I've been in college work
for they're well trained there it's a
specialty now and I
think those whool here the teachers I
trust them to make the best
decision it's not like fixing your pipes
it's a judgment
call and and that's why it's it's hard
to quantify um not that we shouldn't try
I'm not I'm not denying that but
understand it's like a medical decision
in a way it really is how much Med how
many meds do you need uh well anyway
thank you well that's an interesting
analogy but um medicine has been brought
into the insurance World
Quantified so I think the challenge is
surmountable yes representative fellas
so there's there's one thing that um
takes up a large chunk of um any School
District budget and that's
transportation and there's two
categories of Transportation there's
special ed transportation and then just
the regular transportation and in and
instead of trying to somehow say that
all in the a base cost per pupil maybe
we just just a suggestion maybe we might
want to break that category out because
there there's a lot of
variability between rural districts and
you
know more compact districts so you're
suggesting that the portion of
Transportation Services attributable to
special ed students be broken out and
then what would what would you propose
that we do it so actually when we build
our formula here it's not one of the
columns but maybe
Transportation should be one of the
columns
because
um we're we're right now we're not
trying speak special ed Transportation
specifically well maybe special ed
Transportation would go in the special
ed um allocation we're talking about and
regular Transportation would go in
here you could say that when it comes to
the classroom those are pretty
standardized you need a teacher in every
classroom and you know you need some
overhead in terms of you know the
building and operation in the building
and heat and lights and all that but
transportation in my mind is a large
enough category that we might want to
look at that separately and I don't and
I don't have a a suggestion on how to do
it do in terms of like um if it's part
of what they actually pay or we've also
got a state law that says you have to
transport elementary students if they
live farther than it's either one and a
half or two miles from the school but
I'm pretty sure just about everybody is
transporting students that live closer
to
that it's it's just I'm just saying that
it's a large piece of the budget that is
can be very variable from one um School
District to the next and and and also
also has a lot to do with geography and
topography yeah and and the other thing
is I I actually think that we should be
doing this allocation based on
districts rather than
municipalities and one of the reasons I
believe that is that the the on
Claremont ruling said that the state has
to identify describe what is an adequate
education um figure out how much it
costs pay for it and that there has to
be accountability that that it's
actually being provided and you can't
have accountability at the municipality
level because you have Cooperative
school districts where you have multiple
um towns in the school district and they
they don't have say over what services
are provided um only at the district
level do you have a school board that's
responsible for what services are
provided I'm going to go to
representative McGuire in a moment but
just just on that thought
um if we had our Aid directed by
District would you also support then
requiring a district to have a single
local Ed property tax rate for all of
its constituent uh
communities
um so that doesn't happen now no and the
other thing that doesn't happen now it
happens on the county level it doesn't
happen on the school district level oh
correct so and I'm talking about
Cooperative school districts So within
Cooperative school districts you you
could have three towns and
um you might be splitting the budget so
some Cooperative districts it's just
straight per pupil everybody's paying in
the same amount for the pupils that they
send but most of them are not that way
most of them take the budget and this is
common you split the the amount of money
that has to be raised from taxes into
two pieces and half of it you allocate
to the
municipalities based on the number of
students that they have the other half
of the money you allocate based on the
equalized valuation of the towns so what
happens if you go if you do that and
then you look back at what each Town
paid in then you will see that they're
that
um they paid more some towns paid more
per pupil for for their um students in
other towns paid less for theirs and
we're not recognizing it and we're not
recognizing the fact that the towns with
the higher equalized valuation when you
have that split are paying a larger
portion of the budget than their
students represent but we're using the
number of students they have in this
formula when what they're actually
paying is in the sense they're actually
paying for their students plus some of
from the other town and the vice versa
you know so and I didn't really want to
take us off on a a huge tangent because
that's an entirely different
conversation I just wanted to associate
the two ideas if the state is going to
provide its portion of the Aid by
District should the taxation also uh be
and and right now there's no uniformity
across District so let's just hold that
for another time representative Maguire
thank you Mr chairman I just have an
anecdote I guess to to support what
representative fellow said about
Transportation my school has one or more
of these very expensive um specialed
students who are cost total cost
$200,000 a year or more but when I'm
told is that money maybe it's they're
sent to a special school for a tuition
of maybe
$120,000 a year but just the
transportation to get them from Epsom to
the school is $500 a day or $80,000 a
year I mean it's just a tremendous
amount of money not
trial veryy good uh representative
Burton I forgot what it's going to
say okay further
comment well it's it's wide open the
purpose of today is to um cover all the
bases on the adequacy aid anybody want
to take us in a New
Direction representative
Brown thank
you
so thank you so I'm brand new to the
committee
and just been having a few thoughts
about what we're doing here um we're
still debating what the intent of an
adequate education is as we saw this
week uh the scope of the subject matter
and also the breadth of an educational
experience covered is another question
I'm thinking about um when the court
wrote article 83 and I think
1791 they only had grades one through
maybe eight total so are we talking
about an adequate education provided by
the state from K to 12 K to 14 k through
graduate school again unanswered
question
um also if we're jumping the gun on the
courts and moving toward a Statewide
funding
mandate um the Golden Rule comes to mind
he who has the gold decides the
tunes and I think we have had a lot of
discussion about inputs and
representative um lunow had a list of
resources needed in every school that
must be provided to school districts we
focused on inputs but not outputs as
much so when I say the Golden Rule what
I mean
is if we are going to have state funded
programs for local districts we should
focus also on more rigorous
assessments I think local schools do
have you know some interesting ideas for
performance-based assessments but I
think actual rigorous testing is an
important part of Assessments and we
should probably revisit a list of such
tests that we might have districts use
when they assess student
performance um and getting back to the
bills
anyway the bills I like so far since
don't want to jump the gun on the courts
is I like
563 which does raise base adequacy for
some of the
categories the special ed category is
the one with the three categories a b
and c but I think those are um not
really useful categories because if a
student's in a classroom 80% of the time
that 20% they're not in a classroom
could be a very expensive but needed
service so saying they deserve a smaller
percentage or smaller amount may not
work with those time frames classroom
time so I think we should probably just
change the special ed amount from 2100
to something higher and then I also like
uh 717 moving the threshold lower to
three times and from
3.5 and I also like 773
which um does not which requires that we
compensate or reimburse at at least
least 85% or more um for catastrophic
Aid so those are my thoughts for now and
I've been interested in hearing whatever
anyone has to add to that um I really
appreciate all your knowledge thank
you representative Burton I I just
remembered what I was going to say and
and not necessary response to you I I in
the augenblick formula I did the
research on the special ed factor in
other words we had factors times
different situations and it was 1.5 I
believe though that we put in the
formula for any coded students in the
school but then we we invented CAD a for
those really expensive
cases I think that's the way it worked
so that they would get extra aid from
the state for those particular cases so
now 1.5 is probably low these days but
the 1.5 was
what if you had 20 coded students you
got
1.5 uh of the average
costs and we had computed an average
cost I believe that we use in the
formula to determine how much Age and
and the formula is based on assess
values and assess values the Town based
on lot of things but that's the way we
dealt with special uh special Aid when
we were doing that that
formula and it to and again that that
path the house and the
Senate perhaps it would be worth digging
that up and putting it in front of
us I've suggested a few times but they
look at me like I'm way too old to be uh
suggesting such you would catching on
sometimes history is is
helpful sometimes if it's truthful okay
representative ccom and then
representative
fellows thank you
as we sit here and talk about the
adequacy aid and what the right number
is and and calculating it and we talk
about the the cost per student I'm still
hung up on the cost per student and
that we've when you look at what the the
definition of the adequate education is
when we calculate cost per student on
our MS 25s or however it's getting
reported to the state it's not apples
for apples you know we're including
after school programs we're including
the clubs we're including the um Sports
programs as part of our cost of
education and I I personally don't think
that those costs should be calculated
into the adequate education number and
those should be the responsibilities of
the towns to fund because they've
approved those those um extracurricular
items that are outside of the education
portion and yes it can be argued that
there's things to learn from playing
sports um
no question but when we look at our
adequate education and how the state
determines what the average cost per
student is we have a lot of extras in
there and I just it's not a it's not
giving us a fair basis to work with I
think I'm a little confused are you
saying that we have a lot of these other
things you however you want to
characterize them in the calculation of
what constitutes BAS adequacy or are you
saying that that happens to be reported
to the state as part of the expenses of
the school district Mark can probably
say this better than I can but it's I
don't believe that it's part of the
calculation for the base adequacy but it
is part of the
calculation of what the the court and
others are looking at when they see cost
per pupil so when you see $3,000 and
$24,000 that's including after school
activities before school activities um
it may even when I was looking at the
ms25 it may even include adult programs
because there's a line for that but I
would love to have Mark correct me if
I'm saying this incorrectly yeah with
the cost per pup uh metric whenever it's
when it's published and then whenever
it's referenced it's referring to
current expenditures um uh we back out a
few things we back out Transportation um
um as well as some other um um areas but
yeah it would include um all those
additional extra curric ular uh
programming um that would be part of the
current expenditure so that those some
of the programming you T discussed not
um Adult Ed um um because that's lower
down the financial statements and it's
not part of the part of
it is
it sorry it's in the expenditures it's
line six under instruction adult and
Community programs what's the function
code yeah, 1600 to1 1899 so okay so yeah
then it would be it would be included
um um so you if it's uh anything in the
um yeah in the 1600s would be included
uh um so that is in the that is in the
cost per pupo so whenever that number is
referenced it's including those expenses
that um are uh would be considered above
and beyond the cost of an adequate
education above and beyond or it's
included in our cost per pupil
calculation there's um there's
expenditures in the cost per pupil that
would be above and beyond what statute
says is the cost of inadequate education
that's correct thank you and that would
have been my answer as well so they
don't factor into the determination of
uh cost of inadequate
education if I
may it is coming in in my opinion based
on the lawsuits it is coming into the
conversation that the districts are
saying it costs us $23,000 per pupil and
we're not getting enough money so when
they're saying we have to spend 23,000
per pupil and you're only giving us
4,000 or 6,000 or whatever the number is
going to be you're not giving us enough
it's because this is weighted higher
with things that are outside the
adequate education
requirement okay okay I I think you're
getting to the underlying argument about
whether the amount that we're uh
appropriating to cover the cost of
inadequate education is enough and
everybody's got their own opinion about
that um but the question for us is what
are we Bing Gonna Bake into it yes
representative bricky I think was
next okay representative fellas so just
for clarification the cost per pupil is
something that the department Co
publishes it's a report that is
published and it has multiple lines on
it and that's based on what was actually
spent by the school districts but the
court when they're talking about um what
is a adequate you know what does it cost
for an adequate education they weren't
using that number I think didn't didn't
the um conal price out um the adequate
part of it and it wasn't
just any methodology that I've seen to
determine what is the cost of an
adequate educ well I I can't say that
actually um the methodology used in the
2008 report that came up with the 3,500
number that was codified in state law
that number was U essentially just
looked at a teacher a guidance counselor
a principal and said what is the cost of
this individual and then divided it by
number of students to get a per pupil
amount so in that methodology they were
targeting very specific things that they
felt were inadequate education and
tallying up the cost so that was a
methodology used in 2008 that actually
was um codif uh that methodology wasn't
codified but that number 3500 was
codified in state law and so that
methodology didn't look at the whole
scope of cost per pupil um but there
have been exercises that have been uh uh
there's been exercises brought into the
court and cost per people is something
that's been brought into court for sure
as part as the conversation um but the
methodologies used to determine numbers
um have been more narrowly focused to on
things that are necessary to provide a
cost of inadequate education uh you'd
have to read um the conval decision as
far as the methodology they used um cost
per people was likely referenced
multiple times um so it's part of the
conversation but you'd have to study
their methodology and and and determine
um uh your opinion on it essentially so
before I call on representative am I
would just say that if representative
lad were here he would probably Now
bring up his chart which the special
subcommittee carefully reviewed a year
ago but I don't think it's been placed
in front of this committee yet during
this cycle and uh I think we have a
bunch of members who are not familiar
with it but they're they're is a
derived uh formula that in fact supports
the $
4265 which is current uh adequacy number
um so perhaps we'll give him a q to to
uh move in that direction when he
returns and that may be after lunch uh
representative
ases so first I apologize I've been out
uh not here for
however long it's been almost 2 hours
um and uh I've been with representative
luno at another hearing and he's still
there so um so I'm I've been trying to
understand what what's going on here um
and I'm stepping into the middle of it
but it's been pretty wide ranging so
dig okay um but what I wanted to say
just in response to what I've heard is
that
um that the arguments in
core
um that have grown out of the conal
lawsuit and the Rand Rand lawsuit both
active lawsuits conval at the Finish
Line before The Supreme Court in all
respects I believe um and Rand um having
gone through one component of it the
lawsuit that relates to really relates
primarily to swept
um is back before the trial court
justice on this question that that
you're now discussing that we're now
discussing which is uh well how much
does adequacy cost uh
what's how does that relate to what the
state is providing and uh if it is
significantly different is that a
difference that uh defensible or not
constitutionally so in uh in those
arguments the in
conal essentially they took a u the
judge judge Ru was the trial judge and
uh the presenters were um Educators and
experts and particularly the
superintendent of
conal um presented costs real life costs
that were not uh including in in their
presentation as I recall the costs that
are to outside the ambid of the core
academic undertaking of the schools and
uh their undertaking in
that uh trial was the undertaking of the
plaintiffs was to demonstrate and
prove that
4,200 whatever it is something like that
per student as a base
cost um wasn't enough to provide the
fundamentals of uh an adequate education
as it's defined in the statute and uh
they did not use
the per pupil number that's published
that you can get at by looking at the
total budget and dividing by the numbers
of kids and that total budget is going
to
include uh um activities that in this
exercise were not being included and
they come out very differently so in the
trial before J judge ruof he came out
with the conclusion that a little over 7
$7,000 per pupil as I recall 7356 I
believe oh one and one cent and one said
um was
what he I don't recall exactly how he
described it but it was a bare minimum
and probably not enough he
said and uh and that probably when all
was said and done um the right number he
said would be just shy of $10,000 per
student well that is half or less than
the published per pupil numbers that um
that you can get by just taking the
total budget of a a school district and
dividing by the number of students uh so
there's a lot that's being left out of
this adequacy determination because of a
judgment made that at its core a lot of
the costs that are incurred by school
districts although important and perhaps
fundamental to the Enterprise are are
not at that constitutional level and uh
and so that's the general approach
that's been taken in the courts and
we'll see where the Supreme Court how
the supreme court views all of that
hopefully sooner rather than later um I
just want to note that one of the bills
that's before us which I'm involved in
and I don't want to get into it in any
detail because I want because
representative Luna really needs to be
here for that uh is House Bill
772 which is an outgrowth of the um work
that the school funding commission that
was established in
2020 did and uh it's basically it's its
recommendation boiled down into a bill
and into a
formula um and in that bill a different
approach was
taken um
so
that this again I really hesitate to
even get into it it's too complicated
can but but it it looked at the at the
broad array of costs that were being
incurred by school districts and the
performance of those school districts in
terms of student out
outcomes and uh and work through to that
from that to a a budgeted number that uh
would
be sufficient to meet to provide an
adequate education in the Judgment of
this commission and um and then provided
for the payment of that cost in a very
different way than currently is provided
basically a joint undertaking Municipal
and state that um um significantly
increased state aid
but uh and and reduce the dependence on
the localities by looking at the
totality rather than just a piece of it
and uh we need to explore that very
carefully but we I we've got to do it uh
with the prime
sponsor good thought and thank you for
the clear explanation I think that
addressed representative cul's questions
extremely well my suggestion it's now um
10 past uh
noon uh I think that uh let's take our
lunch break now and resume at 1 and
hopefully representative luno
representative lad will uh be back with
us at that time and I think two of the
bills that we really haven't discussed
this morning that are if they were
adopted uh um
transformative are HB
772 the foundation opportunity uh budget
program and HB
675 uh
which uh radically increases the swep
tax so not that we would limit it but I
think that uh those would be two bills
we should focus on after lunch with the
full crowd okay so we'll recess until
one
[Music]
I'm is Avil
okay
e
e e
that'd be great borrowing that a PDF
would be next but this is
useless me
all
right I'm going to call our work session
back into
order um and I believe we have virtually
all the committee with us uh
representative McGuire and
representative lad will rejoin us when
they
can
so I would suggest that we pick up a
couple of the bills in our roster here
that haven't gotten discussion yet um
perhaps start with the HB
675 the Sweeny uh Bill and uh move on to
uh representative luno HB 772 after
that but not too tightly structured just
a
suggestion
so does anybody want
to address this
bill and for some reason I miss placed
my copy but uh this is the bill that uh
dramatically
increases the
swept and uh and then provides base
adequacy at the level of Judge Rua's
opinion in the uh conell
case I guess the first observation that
I would make is that um doing this with
will dramatically increase the amount of
excess swept in those towns that already
experience it and it will also increase
by some maybe undeterminable number the
total number of towns that are in that
position 675
675 so it has some clear benefits and
some clear
abilities so Mr chair yes representative
luno thank you for kicking this off so I
I think there's I think there's three
parts to this bill and I'm not looking
at it right now but but one of the parts
uh adjusted the base cost of an adequate
education to the um the the Court's uh
the superior Court's U finding yep um
73561 correct the second thing it does
is IT addresses the the lower Court's
finding when it comes to excess swept
yes and and uh has the excess swept
remitted to the state and it also
adjusts the um the swept
warrant to um to ra that amount 68% of
the additional
cost that was calculated in the first in
the in the change in adequacy and if I'm
not mistaken that's 773 million correct
correct and then the third thing it does
is impose a um a budget cap on um on on
on local school districts uh along with
a some sort of override 23s or three
fifths
override and a budget cap as distinct
from a tax cap correct
mhm I so I think I think that's the
summary of the of thank you that is a
good
summary yes representative
Damon excuse me thank you so following
up on your initial remarks that it would
increase um the number of districts with
excess swept do we have any more spe
specifics on
that Mark do we have any afternoon
Mark so it I believe that the current
law situation is 43 communities and
$28.6
million uh yes I think it's 28 million
um but
um6 is it 26 or 28 no numbers floating
around 28 I think U
um but um I have a draft fiscal note on
this it has not finished um the review
process internally so um or maybe it has
and it went to the LBA um so you don't
have a fiscal note in front of you um
but I have been looking at doing
analysis I believe I think the number is
maybe 57 towns would become excess swept
so 10 Towns or so would be added um uh
added to the list the excess swept would
um would increase um the way to think
about when you increase base and when
you increase
swept you're increasing base on a per
student basis so when you increase base
adequacy that's based on how many
students you have if you have more
students you get more money because it's
per student amount when you're
increasing swept it's based on your
share of the state's property values so
when you have $1 go up inept $1 go up in
uh sorry $1 go up in base $1 go up in
swept it's pretty much neutral cancel
each other out um but there is when you
actually run a spreadsheet for this uh
bill um it's not going to be perfectly
that your base is going to go up in the
same proportion that your swept goes up
um it's going to be pretty there's going
to be a lot of matching um but it's an
important thing to think about with this
formula is you're increasing base which
is based on the number of students you
have then you're increasing swept which
is based on the the prop your share of
the state's property wealth essentially
um um so just something think about uh
but um the fiscal note um has a cost to
let me see if I can find
it um yeah my number here is 55 excess
swep
towns um so that's getting about 10
Towns are added to the mix
43 to 55 I
believe
yep the um um the impact to um adequacy
so you're increasing re you're
increasing base which is increasing your
cost but you're also increasing swept at
the same time so um you're you're
increasing Revenue at the same time
you're increasing in in cost so it's not
um um the the end adequacy formula is
going to say $1.5 billion um but a lot
of that is going to net out against
swept so
um sorry I'm a little unprepared I got
to find my draft fiscal note so M so M
Mr chair um the the the dollar increase
to to base would would only only apply
to the number of um of students in that
in that municipality in that city of
town city or town
you only get basee for the admr for for
kids yes for the admr so the dollar
increase to swept applies to every uh
taxable piece of property in the town so
so there's obviously
um from cities and towns across the
state you're not going to have a
onetoone correlation or or even a
uniform ratio between the number of
taxable properties and the number of
student
students I think I follow you yeah I'm
just saying that that that um that you
know a a a dollar increase in swept and
a dollar increase in base are just are
two different things
understood so I mean the way that I
understand that the figures in the bill
have been derived are first to take the
uh base adequacy per pupil as dictated
in the court decision and then determine
from that how much swept would have to
be raised to cover it uh even though
it's got all the Varian as youve just
described right but but but I but I
think also a thing that that Mark was
talking about and you and I have talked
about it before too um because it I
think it's it's particularly um evident
in in the town that you in Charlestown
the town where you live uh because I
think Charlestown saw an increase in
valuation that was disproportionately
higher than the average um increase in
valuation across the
state I think that might be true I'm not
totally certain of it but I mean we we
that would be something that you know if
looking at changes in in swept that may
be something that this committee wants
to at least take a look at you know
where just like what Mark said it it um
your proportion is swept has to do with
the proportion of your property
valuation compared to all property in
New
Hampshire yeah it's just a a feature of
this type of formula which is pretty
much our current Formula um just added
additional boost to it but um just
something that um something to
conceptually think about I'm already
getting a um since I have a draft fiscal
note and the LBA has not reviewed it
Mickey's already sending me teams
messages saying he has different numbers
slightly so um we have I I don't want to
speak too much about numbers until I
have a chance for Mickey to review them
um but I can speak conceptually about um
some of the components of the
bill Mr chair okay so so with those now
I don't suppose that this is in the
fiscal note but uh um can you model what
that would look like by town across the
state yeah I built a a a draft fiscal
note that has a town by Town um that
will make its way to the LBA and Mickey
will see if um if he gets the same
result essentially we're looking at a
couple of weeks um uh or days yeah yeah
uh um I don't know I could I could I
could proba try to prioritize it okay
I'm yes
representative I just wanted to clarify
that uh based on the way LBA worked in
the past we're talking days not weeks
because it would be a rough estimate
right it wouldn't be you know fine-tuned
to every little thing but it's what we
need to just have an idea of what the
you know uh changes would be and if I
may really quickly mhm I just wanted to
say that I share the concerns expressed
by you know multiple people testifying
including my colleague from Hopkin on
that because we are not really matching
the expenditures where the funds go to
where the revenues are generated this
seems like it will increase certain
types of inequality in the state and I
think we want to look at Equity we want
to obviously make sure that people
districts who need more help get more
help but to give them more that more
help by leaning even harder on other
communities tends to have certain
negative implications in the state as a
whole that we just got to be careful
about I'm not saying I have a solution
right now but I think those are very
legitimate concerns we should keep in
mind well I think that the real estate
tax is a particularly uncomfortable
source to use for redistribution
purposes and that's part of the uh the
obstacle in this approach I think that
the fact that people could easily
criticize this
approach uh as just simply a
characterization of a certain portion of
the uh property tax from the local Ed
column to the uh U State column um you
know a distinction without a difference
um and it does nothing to alleviate the
burden on those towns that are under
duress representative
Ames well that's I agree um
can swept can easily be
mischaracterized
and identified uh in a way
that's really not in keeping with the
nature of the tax if we if we take it as
a state tax it's not a tax on the
community it's a tax on pieces of
property around the state and then um
because of the way in which the tax has
been this particular tax has been
collected it's collected locally by
municipalities and because of the way it
factors
into uh the payment of educational
costs uh or it has factored into the
payment of educational costs it becomes
a attributed to the
community um the communities paying more
or less as the tax rate goes up and
those property
values sway from one component to
another that uh affects the market value
of property in the town
um and then the sort of possession
that possession impulse that gets into
this and uh and the towns that have a
property value that's going up and
already is up whatever um and
and produce much more at a particular
equalized rate than other
towns
um understandably say well it's our
money don't take it away and when it's
taken away it uh it produces uh losses
which has
happened um and the town
that's having its wealth um T taken by
other parts of the
state have been characterized
historically as donor towns because it's
their money that's going but it's not
really it's it's the individual
taxpayers that are paying this so it's
really a state tax so I suspect this you
stated the other day that the Supreme
Court will see it that way and will
uh um say that it's not in keeping with
the state tax to take uh the money
that's collected and in uh in Ry that
exceeds the uh adequate education amount
that's attributed to Ry
and it's not appropriate to leave that
money in Ry for the benefit of other
things or to pay for other costs
educational costs as it happens in this
case and I suspect the Supreme Court
will come out that way but we don't know
you know you said as much we don't know
you
I I've I've given up on predicting that
Supreme Courts are going to come out
with uh with how they're going to judge
these things but uh it it's a confusing
tax because of all this but it's in a
way it's a tax it's a tax on wealth
that's what it is and um it uh
distributes across the state uh
according to where the wealth
is I think extremely valuable insights
um
the more that we try to categorize
things the more that we uh you know have
to characterize them in in in different
uh
subsets but uh at the end of the day
conceptually um all of the individual
Parcels of property are part of one pool
and that's the state of New
Hampshire and
conversely uh all of the counties and
all of the municipalities are constructs
of the State of New Hampshire so it
works both
ways uh and and uh that's one of the
things that I've s found so
troubling about the uh distinction
between a local Ed tax and a state
tax when it comes to property I think
the real underlying issue is that if you
tax One Source too greatly and if you
tax it in ways that hit different uh um
you know parts of the
population and communities differently
you create pain that can't be
rationalized evenly across the
state representative Flo yeah thank you
Mr chair so um representative Ames
brought up you know um some terms that
that I think probably you know um took
hold more than 20 years ago the the the
donor receiver um um towns and we've
certainly you know over my time here
I've spent a lot of time talking with
members of the Coalition communities and
and uh and um I don't necessarily agree
with with all of their positions because
I agree with what what you just said
very succinctly that that um that the
property base is Statewide and and it's
serving a Statewide obligation in its um
use as a Statewide education property
tax but would would people see things I
mean would it be looked at differently
if rather than being used for Education
it was being used for roads and
bridges I I think that's a very good
rhetorical question um I I think most
people would agree to go back to the
property tax that property tax is a
reasonable
source to provide for
Education um it's interesting uh my town
Charlestown was uh founded on the
Connecticut River in 1730s and 40s and
the very first tax um was authorized to
at town meeting in
1758 to pay pay for hiring a minister
for the Congregational Church that they
were going to create so you know what we
tax for comes in and out of fashion over
time uh but but real estate is a
reasonable
source for supporting education it's
just not reasonable when it's supporting
municipal government County government
and education and all of
it right so it's it's not that it's not
that it's conceptually the wrong place
to look it's that it's too much it's out
of
proportion it's too much yes uh I think
that um
the other feature that Creeps in is that
uh the con
the value of property is not evenly
spread through the state so that um uh
if you're talking about a
Statewide a a uh a
program that's
important that um and make it dependent
on the local wealth
uh for its uh
funding uh the outcome is going to be
uneven uh almost inevitably and we've
got huge differences in wealth between
towns you'll find we'll talk about uh
772 the
uh Foundation opportunity budget bill um
maybe this afternoon but um one aspect
of that bill is that
let's bring that bill in
now we could yeah okay
um yes yeah yep there's no reason to
hold off on it let's integrate
this so one aspect of 772 I'm going to
turn it over to Dave in a moment Dave L
luno representative luno because we're
in a formal setting
um one aspect of of hb77 to is that
it it recognizes that uh this
educational undertaking that we have and
an obligation that we have in uh New
Hampshire to provide for an adequate
education um is an
obligation that is uh placed on the
state
but which um historically has been
exercised fulfilled mostly uh
significantly through through um each
local school district the at a local
level and um that in thinking about
paying
for that obligation which the state
holds it's the state's obligation to
guarantee uh uh the funding of an
adequate
education
um it to pay for that in 772 you'll see
that um we're looking both to the state
state sourced funds and to the locality
so local source to
funds um with the local Source funds
being held to a what you might think of
as a modest level of low level that's
equalized um and that then becomes part
of the pot that's paying for an adequate
education and the
state uh pays for the rest so in a town
that's
uh uh got significant property per
whatever Factor it is per
pupil
um the obligation may be completely
fulfilled by local funding um in a
midlevel town um it would be partially
fulfilled let's say 50% 60% or so will
come from the locality but then the
state pours in the rest uh the 40% or
whatever and then in in a town that has
little value um you know little
significantly less value um per pupil
the the um State comes in with a larger
sum and uh you can measure those sums on
a paup basis so you get some
understanding of what's larger and
what's not um so that feature is in our
bill which uh my I say our bill luno and
myself from representative do
Damon um you see in that bill um that
this is what we're trying to do to
ensure that we're able to fund at a
meaningful level and to do so in an
affordable way that recognizes the
different capacities in different
municipalities to pay for it
just continue running and look at
me
so representative Ames the
$538
um per thousand value Foundation
opportunity is basically an analog to a
swept but conceptually it's we start
here and then we supplement above that
that's I suppose that's one way of
putting that the uh the uh and it's
looking across the state and uh
there's there there are M municipalities
that tax at a lower level you know $2
$3 that have very significant much
greater property wealth from most towns
and uh with that $2 rate they rais more
than enough to meet not only adequacy
aid but a much higher level of spending
on their communities so there are some
many what 30 40 communities that are at
at that low level below the the number
that you just referenced um but if you
look across the state um apart from
those municipalities that can fully pay
for adequacy plus uh with uh a low rate
a rate lower than that number um
practically every other maybe with a
couple of exceptions uh municipality is
at or above that number
$538 um so there's no increase in tax
it's recognizing effort that's already
being made and recognizing it at a
equalized and uniform level and then
building off of
that maybe representative luno yeah I I
would just want to LUN couple of points
thank you very much Mr chair so couple
of points um really important to
772s local share which is the first
dollars in towards your towards your
your um your foundation opportunity
budget first dollars or local dollars
and up to
$538 per thousand and that was based on
a
calculation um that that um that if
every city in town worked towards that
$538 and did not go beyond that so just
like representative am said sometimes
are going to stop at um a buck 50
sometimes are going to stop at
$225 $3 $4 $5
$538 you hit the brakes and what that
would leave as as un still yet to be
funded Foundation opportunity budget it
would leave approximately 4
48% Statewide total some of the budgets
have already been fully funded at $2.50
per thousand up to
$538 hit the brakes and uh and it would
leave a remaining State share of about
40 47% 48% I think we've got 48% in the
um in the in the text to the so if we
look at page 10 of HB
772 in Roman numeral two I think what
you're describing is that the foundation
opportunity budget local
share is the lesser
of
$538 per thousand that's why you said up
to right were 90% of the municipality's
adjusted annual Foundation opportunity
budget
share and
uh and then it goes to calculate how how
the $5 38 cents has arrived at and it
would be
recalculated um every two years every
budget cycle um so that the total of all
local shares is
52% of the total Statewide total of
foundation opportunities so it's
calculated it's designed to raise 52% of
the total required cor correct correct
because if we if we stuck with a with a
fixed number like
$538 as soon as the value jumps up by
another 30 every soete every yeah yeah
so um so that's that's where that's
calculated and
52% is um is right around that's right
around the national average I think so
from a from a from a fiscal policy uh
standpoint that that would move New
Hampshire from being at the bottom of
the of the list in terms of State share
so we're just talking state share now
because that's our perspective here um U
and I forgot where where at 30ish
per 30ish perc moving that up to 47 or
48% puts us right in the mix The Sweet
Spot you know nationally from a from a
from a fiscal policy uh perspective and
um and it doesn't lock us into uh to a
number like $530 I mean $530 was
calculated based on our most recent
valuations it doesn't lock us into um uh
to that down the road the the the other
thing that's Point that's really
important to make is while it while it
shares some of the same purpose as our
current swept meaning it knocks the
first dollars off the um the budget um
it is in no means a state
tax the only thing uniform about it is
it doesn't go higher than
$538 but like like representative am
said for for approximately 50ish towns
it's going to be less than
that and um and so there's uh there's
nothing pretending it's it's not
pretending to be a state tax it's
nothing like like a state tax um that
said
772 does not get rid of the Statewide
education property tax either so it um
it it does reform it based on the the um
lower court order that um that um uh
that it it behaved like a state tax and
that um that cities and towns do not get
to retain excess over and above the um
cost of an adequate education and in
fact the way 772 works is they collect
the um the swept locally and the swept
out okay still $363 million they collect
it locally and they send all of it up to
the um to the to the treasury so you
don't you can't even you can't even do
some of the things that that like have
you know negative tax rates and things
like that that that some some um um very
small
uh towns um do and these are towns that
you know are are large townships yeah
largely you know you know very few um
very low population maybe no students at
all
so so it's just want to clarify that and
then I'll come to representative buron
um on page 18 we still have the
Statewide education property
de and I'm not sure I've processed all
this but basically the um Foundation
opportunity budget local share up to
$538 per thousand plus plus the swept
would both be mandated by this law on
the property tax
right representative
Burton uh yeah I know you weren't here
this morning for the conversation but
I'm wondering how you account for uh rep
Maguire's problem when two
$200,000 IEPs arrive in a poor
town um should we
make should how do they how would they
because that's what many towns are
concerned about how is that accounted
for in in this
bill what I'm getting at if it helps
repo that when we did the organ blck
formula which was discussed this morning
because we had the author of it here uh
that's when we came up with cat CAD a
that I think we set up if an IEP was
over 50,000 or something like that this
is
1986 8 87 um then the state would take
care of it like every other free country
does yeah I think that I so now now I'm
now I'm hearing your question um so so
House Bill 772 isn't a circuit breaker
build so it's about a a school funding
formula that um that works that is fair
that is is uniform for for everybody
everybody follows the same formula and
most importantly and this is what we
talked about during the introduction um
it there are things that it doesn't have
that our current formula does it doesn't
have any
props to make it work it works by itself
and so it doesn't have a hold harmless
it doesn't have a built-in stabilization
it doesn't have a extraordinary needs
Grant component um because the and the
our current form has an extraordinary
needs Grant because the formula by
itself doesn't work for places like
Manchester I guess just a question is we
might have to consider a circuit breaker
program of absolutely absolutely isn't
the whole picture thank yeah I think uh
that's the important point that um this
formula does not displace the uh high
cost special needs placement funding
that's separately required because it
incidence is not predictable and uh it's
not spread in a way that other costs are
spread so this addresses general
education and not the special needs
that's your point right no no it it it
it it definitely addresses special needs
and when you when you take a look at how
the formula gets built out let's see if
I can find
it um on page seven
yeah and it you and it it does this um
in fact it's it's page page seven
starting in line 23 so Roman 3 um talks
about a weighted admr which is which is
a a way of saying that um that that
different um differentiated Aid factors
have different weights to them and and
that's consistent with what we do right
now so we have a base of of of where
where are we at 40
42 4200 base I'm just going to round up
42 4265 4265 base we have a
$2,300 uh differentiated Aid component
for special education is a 23 23 for um
fnr 21 20 21 for special education 23
for for free and for free and reduced
price lunch um students 700 7 750 yeah
well it's 832 832 for English language
Learners so so those different dollar
numbers are like different weights so so
so so I'm seeing in lines 27 through uh
32 that this addresses the free and
reduced concept corre addresses English
language Learners and IT addresses
special ed correct but it does it
through these weights correct correct
and then and then the reason for using
weights so that they're automatically
adjusting yep and they and they and all
the weight tie back to one a single um
value which is the
base got it like multipliers I'd like to
ask a question that because
representative ask a question regarding
that so now for example with the special
education weight of
4.29 what is the base dollar
amount so so the the base that I think
we've got in it's at page uh
line
13 okay your Universal cost then is
$7,000
,31 and and so so another thing to keep
in mind here what what we're what we're
seeing on page page
seven going on to the top of page eight
is is the construction of the foundation
opportunity budget amount and so this is
the amount for school district to
educate all of its um provide an
opportunity for an adequate education to
educate all of its students to a
Statewide outcome which is a strong
outcome in New Hampshire
and and so so while while the number
that it calculates
for Hopkinton I'll just pick where I
live um might end up being a little bit
less than hop son's school budget for
for school districts that have have
struggled to put together School budgets
it might be greater than their school
budget for instance Newport uh Newport
has a lot of uh lot of students who have
IEPs and um and and so so building
building a budget using this formula
it's actually going to look like a lot
like a school budget but um so it it it
treats it treats
costs separately from
funding so we we you know we cost out
something that really looks like what
what schools are doing um right now and
then it funds it not not it doesn't fund
every dollar of those costs with State
dollars it starts with a with the local
share and then comes in with the state
share if your if your local share
doesn't um doesn't get you there so um
so you know separating out costing from
funding is uh is is I think sort of
central to the to the difference the
different approach that that we're
proposing in in
772 um different than than than a l than
every other bill that we've we've looked
at that um um that that basically you
know cost some costs out inadequate
education and funds every dollar of that
with with through state
taxes representative L yeah um staying
on this then and looking at the the
weights for these various categories and
if we have a weight of 4.29 here or
another weight of
2.2 are these weights interrelated so if
I subtract a 0. 29 from one I'm going to
have to add another 0. 29 to another no
because the number of kids are
different okay um so what brought about
for example in special education where
you're going to multiply four times the
Seven Grand that's you know 28 um what
how did you determine that a 4.29 was
necessary versus a 3.5 well you were you
were with us I know I was there t I
wasn't buying into it either so well
well you know we uh we we did work with
a so this was during the 2020 um school
funding commission and um we contracted
with the the American institutes for
research uh who have experts both in um
in in school policy and school funding
uh policy and what they were able to do
is take a look at what every one of our
school districts has been doing you know
by virtue of looking at the ms25 the
doe2 and how money was being spent in
each of those districts they were able
to isolate uh any spending that that and
I'll just use the term didn't move the
needle very much in terms of student
outcomes so they were able to discount
for that and then they were able to to
calculate these weights based on um
based on you know how many you know how
many students um in a in a district uh
were um were uh had IEPs let's say let's
just talk about the special education
part and um and how did that how they
would look at at how that District spent
money for those for those IEPs and what
the student outcomes were for the
average student outcome in that district
and they were able to compare that to
every District in the state and um and
by by by looking at all the student
outcomes looking at all the student
spending they were able to put together
a weight for each one of these
differentiated Aid factors the the um
the the free and reduced price lunch
which approximately which is a a proxy
for uh for lowincome backgrounds English
language Learners special education uh
uh we have size of the school district
was actually a weight that uh that we
use and each one of of them had
different uh different factors uh to it
and uh and then through a regression
analysis uh they looked at the um the
you know where where the um you know
where where
where where each District's calculated
Foundation opportunity budget would go
would be so they calculated um uh a
foundation opportunity budget for each
school district and then drew a a best
line through all of those so some are
going to be bigger some are going to be
smaller Dre a best line that fit um to
give you to give you these
weights so it's not perfect it's not
perfect but but with a with a high
degree of correlation correlates to
getting you to the budget you
need so to to somebody who's not really
been inside that process or involved
with the mathematics of the regression
analysis this does a look a little bit
black box like you know throw in turn
the gears and we'll tell you the number
later
where regression puts me into regression
and depression um the uh my question
though is that when you mentioned those
categories how do you account for a
student who is on an IEP but also low
income and also this do you did they did
they fractionalize the those students
somehow they're not I that student would
be counted in each one of those
categories um and that's where the
student specific characteristics come
into play because it requires a same
amount of effort for each one of those
categories that might be in type or or
different yeah I mean a different
depending upon what the what the
categories are but I also want to
address the Black Box comment too so so
a single student could trigger several
of the allowances absolutely as as they
would do in our current uh funding form
sure thank you um but but you know so
finger in the air where did
$2,300 um come from for um for free
introduced price lunch students finger
in the air where did
$2,100 come from special education I
would offer I would offer that based on
what I'm hearing at um School District
deliberative sessions what I've heard so
far this year during our committee work
on Co real costs for special education
that the the the 28 ,000 um increment
here the weighted increment we're here
here for a special education student is
a lot closer to what schools are are um
what what the true cost is to uh to
schools right now than
$2,100 so I'd say the $2,100 is sort of
in the Black Box I don't think
empirically you can uh you can could C
you could calculate that but but but
these numbers are actually being
calculated um
I think for all of us uh and and some of
us are newer to this the mechanics of
this bill are um demanding right to but
fundamentally what you've been
describing here with these weights is
not the determination of the state's Aid
itself it's the determination of the
budget um right the foundation
opportunity budget corre for a
particular uh District so if we just
accept uh these
mechanics once we've established the
budget now take the funding process the
next couple of steps and describe for
everybody the mechanics of how this
plays out sure sure so um so once once
every District once the Department of
Education has calculated the foundation
opportunity budget for for every
District based on using these weights
applied to the number of students that
fall into each of these categories get
you a total number for uh for each each
School District the first dollars to
fund that budget come from the local
share so this is let me yeah go no go
ahead yeah
one intermediate
step that we're skipping over that
little closer to the one intermediate
step that we're skipping over in moving
from the budget the foundation
opportunity budget number to
the pay for side that you're starting to
talk about no I'm not talking about the
pay I'm talking about well local talking
about the local share yeah which is
paying for yeah okay
um in the bill we have
a further Factor applied to that
Foundation opportunity budget that's
been developed through the application
of the weights and the numbers of pupils
um we reduce the bill reduces
the foundation opportunity budget number
by 10% it's called an efficiency factor
it's basically a policy determination
that
um we want to we don't want to be too
high we want to
uh sort of so it's it's der it's I'd say
it's it's derated by an efficiency
Factor yeah is so and then it is further
and I'm glad you you pointed this out
representative Ames and then it's
further derated by a transition a phase
in that's right period so so in its
first year um I'm seeing the phase in on
page nine correct right in the middle of
page nine and where's the efficiency
Factor uh we have to look for
it efficiency Universal efficiency see
page 8 line
14 there you go okay thank you shall me
90% Y and then and then that would get
multiplied Again by 86 in in the first
year this is an adjustment to the
calculated opportunity budget correct
okay and and um and so so that will
then starting with the found the
calculated Foundation opportunity budget
from all the
weights discounted by the efficiency um
90% so um further discounted by a phase
in Period gets you an adjusted
Foundation opportunity budget I think I
got the terms right and and and now you
start to figure out how to fund that
adjusted Foundation opportunity budget
just to interject I guess one other
feature that we didn't specifically
discuss yet is there's also a factor
that um adjusts Bas on the size of the
student stent population in a given
distance that's the school size correct
y yeah I I did mention that quickly but
you're you're right that's that's
something that's not currently in our in
our formula but we have that information
it's a piece of information the
department has for every school district
can I make a ask a question yes
represent when I read this whole thing
and um finally starting to understand it
when I came out of regression was that
um what does it do to the role of the
local school board who
traditionally have to deal with a budget
it looks like it would be helpful
because it would tell them what their
budget might be now if if a town wants
to go above this they could but it it
may take some of the steam out
of uh those budget discussions it it
definitely could I mean it could put
School boards in a position where they
need to justify why their budget is is
different than than the foundation
opportunity budet a b deal but
fundamentally no this is a you hit on
something really important here um
represent Burton that that this whole
exercise here ultimately takes you to
the calculation of a state
Grant and that's at the end of the day
that's what the School Board needs to
know so that and that's what the the
voters in town need to know because it's
the combination of the school Grant plus
plus
what
what you know plus whatever's needed to
hit your ultimately the school uh
District voters can vote to um you know
fund anything they want to sky's the
limit but but but but this determination
of the grant goes through the vehicle of
a commonly understood budget formula so
even the
$538 that we're talking about that's
just in here to calculate what what the
remainder would be so that a state Grant
could be calculated um it's not it's not
that schools have to raise $5 38 it
doesn't set a limit or restrain the
schools so that's correct so so the the
the we've now talked about the costing
portion the funding portion is that up
to
$538 to hit this adjusted Foundation
opportunity budget um if you're there
great you're there if you're not there
the state comes in with with um with
State funds and get some other source
and makes up the difference and gets you
to the foundation opportunity not not a
dollar more than that just to the
foundation opportunity budget and if um
if you're um yeah Ju Just like what what
um representative spillsbury said if um
if your school district has decided to
spend uh to spend more then that's on
you the state's not going to get you to
that higher number um that's on that's
on the voters of the
district so of course this bill also
does not address what sources the state
may look to to make up the difference um
that's yeah just just not within the
Ambit of this bill it it it it does make
changes to um to the the um the
mechanics behind the Statewide education
property tax so there's no retained um
discount accounts or excess or anything
like that it
um and it doesn't change any other um
any other taxes it it does however have
a make a substantial change to the low
and moderate income property tax relief
program and I would I would turn that
over to to representative Ames uh to
talk about because that's that's also
contained separately in a um in a a in a
bill parallel to
this before you leave that point would
it also be possible if if we ran this
these numbers through a state model we
could predict how much the state would
have to kick in right correct correct
and and you could also um you could also
by by every city and town take a look at
how the foundation opportunity budgets
compare to let's say what they voted in
last year as a school budget and um
and you know you could even model how
much additional um um you know money
that um that that voters in the town
might want to you know put in if they
wanted to have something higher than the
than the foundation opportunity budget
but it's not required and it doesn't
change the um uh the the Grant from the
uh uh from the state uh and you can you
can and I I don't think the the
LBA um typically get into tax rate
impact um no they do not right so so um
so there we there there is actually I've
showed this to to um showed it to
somebody recently uh but uh in the um in
the body material that that the uh
school funding commission created uh we
also have a um a a funding simulator on
there it's obviously five it's based on
2020 uh 2019 and 2020 uh data but um but
and it's hosted at the website managed
by the Cary school and it's it's
basically it's an Excel model and you
can um you can type in whatever numbers
uh you want and you can see the impact
on your your local tax rate based on
2020 uh dollars and 2020 evaluations so
but uh but you know assuming proportions
might might carry through you can see
that you can see how that would uh would
be relevant to your cities and towns as
a representative of relatively property
poor towns uh if I was looking for how
that's handled in this bill basically
it's the idea that the um Foundation
contribution is limited to
$538 and if your Town's valuation your
your grand list is uh relatively small
your $538 per th000 value only pulls so
much weight and that's where the state
steps in above that so that's exactly
right the Gap is greater correct there
there's one other feature that we
haven't mentioned in this um just to
make it a little more
complicated sure why not why not um
person
the the property
the the high property level
towns
um who that are able to
meet the foundation budget cost the cost
of a of the foundation budget for their
town with a rate lower than
$538 don't have to go to
$538 they stop not not at 100% of the
foundation oper opportunity budget but
at 90% of it the state kicks in the last
10% so every town will get some
something and that means every town has
a stake in this system that we've
created it's not just for the poor guys
and and the rich guys uh play their own
game thank you for everybody's in the
same game that that takes us back to
page 10 Roman numeral 2B right the
limiting uh 90% Factor yeah okay that's
right good um other questions no
question is a dumb question here this is
a lot to Grapple with do we have other
questions about how this actually would
work either 675 or 772 we can go back to
either of
those yes I got a question on this one
um
we had the superintendent of schools
come in who talked to us about how she's
28 teachers short so she can only hire
non uh certified teachers and then as
soon as they get their certification
they move
on um according to your criteria for
hiring I don't even see how this can
even alleviate her situation can you
sort of help me with that well
well yes so there there's no there's no
criteria for certification in in this no
there nobody for hiring it's on your
list of right so so so the the bill
basically calculates or the you know
what this is proposing is is it it
calculates a budget that would be
necessary for for that every school
district including the school district
that's 25 minutes from from my house
where we had the superintendent testify
from Newport um and and it would
calculate a school budget I suspect for
Newport that is higher than the budget
that voters are approving right now even
with these the I think second highest
property tax local prop school property
tax rate in the state and uh and and
they come up far short in being able to
uh to hire um to hire uh credential
teachers uh because the budget just
doesn't isn't enough so so the budget
that comes out of this is designed to
address those problems from a budgeting
standpoint if they've got Workforce
problems due to you know availability of
housing or Transportation or other
things no this bill this bill does not
address uh address that uh but that's
not what I heard from the the the
Newport soup was I think very clear that
that their budget did not allow them to
to uh to hire and retain teachers is
that cons yeah yeah great once again my
district gets raised as an example
representative fich
Miller thank you Mr chair um I was just
curious if somebody could comment on
whether this bill does address the
different costs that are needed to run
schools in different geographical areas
of the state because obviously the needs
of K County the needs of Rockingham the
needs of Hillsboro tend to be very
different where in this largish bill
would be you know those Provisions if
any of those are there no thanks thanks
for the question um I would need to
actually look back Rick's got a copy of
the sorry represent lad has a copy of
the report uh right there and and we we
the school funding commission certainly
looked into Geographic um uh variations
in terms of costs whether that's can I
speak that yeah please um this was a a
discussion item that was a result of the
whole commission looking at these small
schools years ago I had submitted a bill
dealing with small rural geographically
isolated
schools and when I came to present that
I was really torpedoed by one of our
Senators Senator Lou de
delandro and it was over the fact he
said well what we're going to do in
Manchester we're just going to make all
our schools small and so we'll get this
extra dollar well what we end up doing
in this and there there's there's
portions of this which I Concur and
agree to but there's other portions
which I don't this is one area though
that um we we change so it doesn't say
say that you get this weighted amount
for schools it's weighted amount for
school
districts so a district is a total so
you take that total popul population if
it was weighted towards a small school
like a well of course you know you have
small districts like cin but you know it
does eliminate the fact that Manchester
is not going to be able to you know come
up with you know 30 40 small schools and
get this added weight you know and that
I've seen where I've lived in certain
places like in Alaska that this did
occur and so uh I think that this this
Factor right here does eliminate the
being that portion of the weighted value
being abused representative Pap mishar I
think you want to follow up well I I
would appreciate it I I I found that
very informational but I didn't
necessarily feel that it addressed the
whole different costs of living in
different parts of the state based on
what I've heard it seems to I haven't
caught any part where it would address
this and again cost of living in you
know Rockingham County by the mass
border are very different in cost of
living in Co County and they are very
different in Hillsboro and they are very
different in every County right poor
smooth versus kin and so on so is there
anything in this bill that would address
that because we do provide this guidance
budget right and I just want to
understand if that budget does account
for those cost of living slash cost of
hiring teachers and so on and so forth
we have a diverse State no there there's
there's nothing that addresses that U
because the formula applies would it be
fair to say though that what the Bill's
driving at is how the state's portion
were Aid is is determined but what the
district then decides to do on its own
is entirely still a local decision right
but but but I would ALS I think to your
to your question though is is and I want
to I want to refer back to the report
and if you don't have a copy of it there
are copies in the in the office but um
but as I recall um representative Ames
do you um yeah as I'm not going to be
able to find it right now but but as as
I recall we did look into what are the
the cost variations in terms of in terms
of if I wanted to hire a a a teacher in
in
Littleton um how would that compare to I
want to hire a teacher in Windam and um
and and so I wanted defer back to that
report uh to to see what it concluded
yeah if I could add to that um that's my
recollection as well I think the the
conclusion on this very able cost issue
you know it's more expensive here than
there that's basically what you're
asking about yeah
um at that time and this commission was
that there's not
enough
to um lead it wasn't enough to lead us
to address that directly but there is an
obligation to revisit all of these
weights and maybe a new
weight um
periodically I can't remember the uh
right right every every 10 years every
10 years um and uh that would be fair
game and uh you know New Hampshire's a
funny state it's
got but that would also be something
that we want to have have data
collection from the Department on that
so that weights could be calculated in
there's a whole section i' like on where
they are first before you jump is that
on the same topic okay okay
representative Burton has been patient
I'm never patient but that's okay thank
you I just want to add uh the judge in
the conel case struggled with this issue
and he wrote a whole page on starting
salaries because they ran from 36,000 to
670,000 so he finally determined that
the correct number was
$52,000 and with
$552,000 average salary in a school
district he figured that would include
some beginning faculty and some
experienced faculty so when he did this
formulation that was the number he he
used just as an aside he threw the
Oyster River District out my district
because our abts teacher salaries up in
the 70 grand area we're a University
Town high expectations and so forth but
52,000 was the average he came up with
and a $40,000
$42,000 entry salary
represent mes just to this point about
cost variations on page
six um line 30 31
32 as part of an obligation that the
general court has to determine the value
of an adequate
education um
periodically
um the cost model shall evaluate the
relative impact of the following
attributes that affect the differential
cost of achieving any given level of
outcome and assumed to be outside the
control of districts so Regional cost
factors would be outside
the uh and and then the items are
variation in student needs the second
one is geographic variation in the price
levels of necessary specific resources
resource elements it's there you
know it's hard to work with hard to make
judgments about
yeah representative flad when we
discussed this this aspect I got very
involved with it because one of the
school buses I had in Alaska was a
hydrofoil we had hydr foil we had and
the person who run that had to be a a
registered pilot um just to get the kids
from the other side of the lake where
there no roads and and so here in this
state we have some districts which are
small and isolated and their
transportation costs for high school
where they don't have that available in
that small District um are extremely
high just like it is in Maine where you
have matinicus and monh monhagen Island
where they have to send their kids off
the island for that education kid
expenses just roar we don't have some of
those things to the degree but we do
have small schools when you're looking
at efficiency of scale when you get
smaller and smaller and smaller but we
by rule and by Statute say You must have
X Y and Z and you don't have the number
of students to help pay for X Y and Z
your costs are going to go up and so
that's I think one good reason why this
was put in there I I struggled with it
when we're on the commission but it's I
think it's it's a very positive thing
and like representa am says that it's
something can be looked at in the future
uh I would hope if we ever get into a
model like this or if we even take some
of these weighted portions out and using
in another model um that we explore this
uh it's worthy of pursuing many many
states have this value in there
transportation is really an expensive
item for school districts and it will
increase in these small districts so we
don't have hydro foils but we do have
240 miles of bus route and Mr chairman M
heagan has a school I've been in it uh
they have a one room Schoolhouse and
every year they argue with the crediting
body uh I've been in it and it's a good
school and their kids go on to colleges
and so forth yeah I can say my wife's
mother worked in matinicus well
matinicus is different def you're off
the coast for quite a w there 10 miles I
and all those along the iboro and all of
them uh we we they have concerns I think
we were shooting to uh wind up around 2
o'clock does anybody want to make a
further contribution before we well I do
have one last question that I I didn't
get the pose to uh both represent Ames
and represent luno one of the concerns
which I had when when we were looking at
this was that we were looking at how do
we arrive at that what we want education
to cost and you're looking at the you
know the performance-based outcomes and
accountability which I agree but when we
used the data we did not have the type
of data that I would like to see the
doe2 form did not disaggregate
uh the the portions of those expenses
which were directly related to the
opportunity for an adequate education
versus other expenses which don't come
fall underneath adequacy in statute but
they're optional services that you know
you as a district can pay for
so I guess where I am is I in order for
me to really you know appreciate the the
costs which are going to result from
this thing I'd like to know how are we
going to ever be able to disaggregate 20
form we can take out tuition and
transportation that's done in there but
the rest of it's not and uh often times
we look at and that that's the average
cost per pupil well is it really in
terms of the opportunity for adequate
education which we speak to in this
legislation yeah so so um you know like
we talked about earlier the um the
American institutes for research who who
did the work and and did the regression
uh analysis on on on what what goes into
a um uh a public school education did
look at all the costs so not just the
costs ass associated with the um with
the um uh you know
1932a content areas uh but uh but no it
looked at um it looked at costs and it
looked at how those
costs affected student outcomes and um
and you know what what what you know
what are the costs for co-curricular
activities um I mean we we we talked
about I think on a on another unrelated
Bill to this about how um how your first
step is to get your students to walk
through the door and there's a lot of
factors that come into play for that
because different students are motivated
different different ways might be who
they're sitting next to but it also
might be I want to play in on um
Friday's football game and I know the
coach says if I don't if I don't come to
school I don't come to practice and I
don't play the game and um and so so all
those things were were were analyzed in
terms of an impact on um on student
outcome and and representative mahagan
and I talked about well what if I don't
have a marching band do I need to get a
marching band no you don't need to get a
marching band um we're not this bill
does not tell your your um your
superintendent or your building
principal
what to do and how to and how to do it
and and you know the the interest and
the impact that a marching band might
have in Salem OR Windam or Londoner I
understand The Londoner band I think
does a lot of uh of uh travel uh across
the country and maybe even
internationally um may have a different
impact in London der than it has in
Handover or Hopkinson and um and it's
really up to the to the professional
experience
of your your your local superintendent
building principles to Define what um
what what these things are to give give
the U the the best outcomes for your
student but but looking at it across the
state in all districts um that
Foundation opportunity budget does
include does include these um the the
the the cost to offer programs beyond
the the 13 how many elements do we have
in 1932a 11 11 the 11 elements in there
and um and and I I don't think there's
any District in the state and I think
we've heard many people talk about that
there's not a single District in the
state that offers just those 11 elements
and stops there and um um you know I'm
I'm not sure you know what and but you
know our our current our current model
talks about offering the 11 the those 11
elements and stops there what we're
proposing here we're not we're not
taking away those 11 elements but we are
incorporating in the student outcome
factor and um and at the end of the day
I think that's what what Granite Staters
want for um for all their kids is to uh
to perform at a at a high level like we
are doing on average just not happening
everywhere and you slip into there a
very important point which is that um
the list of the topics that make up
inadequate education do not limit
schools and never intended to limit
schools in terms of what they offer
absolutely representative uh Ames I'm CL
I'm not sure who okay he's got
seniority bar
barely
um two
things one is that I think it's
important to say that going
through the calculations and the formula
that's in House Bill
772 leads to
results that increase significantly some
towns
and not so for other towns and it tends
to scale according
to um according to property
wealth um and also according to the
relative needs of kids and some element
of size is in there too but uh there are
differentials and that means that
compared to the other formulas that
we're looking at the base increase
formula the base plus differential Aid
formula um the cost of this program
bottom line comes out at less than
significantly less than the costs of
those other
programs and
um the second thing I want to say is
that I will uh I think I I will do this
I will send to everybody the uh
spreadsheet uh with is an Excel with the
formulas in it of what I've put together
with the understanding that the a
draft um we do not yet have from OS the
fiscal statement but we're into this
we're trying to talk about it understand
that I'm uh I'm not the best with Excel
I got clumsy fingers and uh my schooling
uh occurred long before the development
of
EXL um so um I will I will do that and I
think that will enable you to see how
this plays out in a way in which you can
play with the data yourselves um and
understand that when the the experts
weigh in he's gone
um the numbers for the foundation
opportunity budget may prove to be a
little bit different but basically they
build off of the work that Mark did two
years ago on the predecessor Bill to
this bill well that sounds extremely
helpful and I I think the black hole
obviously that is in front of us today
is we don't know what the fiscal note
suggests will be the cost of the state
of making up the differential um so
representative lad uh can you yeah and
representative Burton yeah I too grow up
with a Blackboard and chalk and DK well
on the desk with the quill pen you and I
are the same same but uh and dealing and
going back to where I was on this and
am the we've talked I as I came into
this part way soon I apologize I had we
my Microsoft did a number on us today
um when when I've been looking at at the
way this has been computed as far as the
dollar using the
outcomes and I'm I'm I'm seeing that
there are costs which have been talked
about in the committee here earlier
today when we we heard that if a local
wants to go beyond and expand an
enrichment program they can do that
that's going on right now in this State
there are school districts which were
offering much more than others they want
to enrich that's the expectation that's
what the families want that's what the
community wants that's what the
workforce
wants that's the way our doe 25 form
that's it reflects all that in the doe
25 form today I believe there we we
can't be basing everything off th those
communities we should take the high and
the low out and find out what's in the
middle and what the actual cost is on
these doe 25 forms we're going to look
at statistics and but because what we're
doing by not disaggregating this data
then we're going to find out well the
average cost is $7,000 or whatever it is
uh it may be but it's also involving all
those enrichment programs which are
occurring throughout this state it's
going well
beyond what we expect for the
opportunity of an adequate
education and I understand that you know
they're nice things to have but some of
those nice things have gone beyond you
know the actual need they've gone and
gone
farther we should be building a building
on a budget on that uh I'd like to have
the inputs that are necessary to say
this is what your adequate education is
build off those inputs you can use a
formula like this but let's start with a
figure that is one that is palatable at
least to myself that reflects what the
inputs
cost representative Burton one of the
resources we had when we did this
formula was anytime we changed anything
we got a whole new computer model with
uh Dean Mitchner I don't know if anyone
remembers him he may he was anist yeah
but he ran these these things so we
could actually see what was going on um
by the way adequate is not a great
standard for Education none of us want
want adequate we want exceptional for
our kids um the last thing I'm going to
say is
this I envy business people because you
can measure your output we use output
outcomes the true output of education is
the increment in intellectual and
personal growth of person experiences
well going through it now if you go to
Harvard and you've got 2 800
SATs you're one thing but if you come up
if you're immigrant from the Dominican
Republic like I had many of them and
you're seeking a new life here um and
and you learn English and you learn a
skill that is also a successful output
but the the problem you're working with
is we don't know what the outputs are
but we know what the inputs ought to be
and and we know that they can they can
vary um that that my sermon for the day
but all right any other sermons any more
sermons no that's that's illegal on
public money isn't it representative
fellows yeah um I don't I don't know if
this will be helpful for representative
lad or not but back in about
2002 to come up with a base cost um what
what I remember is taking the state
assessment
results and sorting all the districts
based on the T the test um results and
then um you know putting putting the
best performance at the top and the
lowest at the bottom cut it in half take
that top half and sort that again based
on expenditure per pupil or some kind of
cost per pupil and then take the um the
lowest the lowest um
expenditure per pupil and that was the
data I don't remember the details that
use used to come up with the um per
pupil base
cost so the only thing that
um is you have to make some accommodate
which they didn't do but I think you now
now we know better to make some kind of
accommodations for the fact that the the
biggest um communities would come out
came out in in that because the because
because of economy as scale you know you
get the Manchester and the Nash is in
the bigger districts so you need to put
back in for the the smaller districts
that that it's inherently going to be
more per student for the smaller
districts because they can't build and
and I personally I think we need to look
at some kind of funding that's on the
classroom level
because some districts you you can't
control the number of students that you
put in a classroom for the smaller
districts because they've got to fit in
between that you know they've got to
keep it below the 30 or the 25 but when
you get 35 students you have to split
them into two classes so you can't get
the same kind of economy and skill you
get in the bigger one so that's just
just another way of looking at it to put
on the table we see that in terms of of
the University system to keep the
conquered law school going you're going
to have to have another program over
here and so it's just this bubble you're
pushing in so there are those one
Department might be carrying another
department but you need both
departments and and within schools it's
very much the same I get that and but
there's other ways of of doing the
assessment I was around when we used
those types of Assessments the norm
reference tests to really derive a a a
costing formula but there's other
outputs too which are really important
uh other than you know I I had a brother
at 800 on the College Board scores
flunked out of college three times in
mathematics 800 now he's in charge of
bull computer over in Europe but I I
think that there's other other
performances that we can do we have
those IND indices in our how do we judge
which we're meeting an adequate
education how we reporting to Essa and
there you know how many go on to the
trades how many go on to college how
many go into the service how many you
know are participate in this program or
that that's how I think we should be
measuring outcomes along with those the
testing scores I think that's extremely
important so I don't want to really
build it on one type of
instrument I that's sort of like this
budget does that I I did a complete cost
analysis that you Ag and it and you
can't go by that the most expensive
program they have is nursing because the
ratio of of Faculty full-time faculty to
nurses is 10 to one that's very
expensive the next was technology the
next was the business school I was
assistant dean of and then uh liberal
arts funds the rest of them because they
have these huge intro sections and and
so I most most colleges are like that
and that's why they're nonprofit because
inherently uneconomical from a cost
standpoint but it's inherently
beneficial from a social Viewpoint we
need
nurses so I
so say I think we're at about the wrap
up Point yeah yeah so so I think as the
fiscal notes begin to um come out for
this for 772 and and um and the other
bills you know taking a look at a couple
things taking a look at what the bill is
trying to accomplish and taking a look
at at at the costs at what the what the
costs to the state are and um and I and
hopefully I think you know because we're
looking at different um different
methods here from all these different
bills that uh that there'll be something
there to contrast and uh and I don't
think you're going to see two bills that
are like oh yeah it doesn't matter which
one we pick they both do the same thing
I think there'll be significant contrast
between between these and um and uh I
hope we have uh more of these work
sessions coming up soon with fiscal
notes I agree with everything you've
just said and I think that once we have
the fiscal note yes another discussion I
think this was a very well balanced day
we we went through a whole series of
bills that tweak our current uh approach
before lunch and then we talked about
two bills that would fairly radically
transform it so um obviously we can't
cover everything today and and we'll
revisit those yeah how thought I pass it
back to our Jim well I think we're ready
to get out of here at least I am um it's
been a hard day you know when our
reports came they didn't come and they
came in about two hours after you sent
them uh Microsoft had a problem pardon
me from you all I got twice I got it
twice yeah but they all came in on the
same time when I just walked in here is
when I got them uh so uh we have uh
nothing scheduled for uh the remainder
of this week and other than session
tomorrow the governor doing her big
thing and uh then we will meet again on
Tuesday and we meet on Tuesday at 10:30
10:30 we'll be starting and we are going
to be executing the bills that are I
think it's 11 or 12 bills that we we're
executing uh we're we're not attacking
any of these th this what we discussed
today on at that time those bills are
still being yes your representes you're
right on and we're going to have to
figure out which bills we're going to
work with which ones we're going to keep
to work further on um and on so so more
or less the bills for next Tu day are
the uh meals bills and the higher ed
bills meals and higher and there there
are some other bills too which are just
unto themselves that that uh
there's there's two bills which are
March 20 due dates everything else is
early bill is is it in the calendar
those bills that will be it's not won't
be in the calendar till probably Friday
it's they've been just submitted just
now yeah yeah per me you might get it
tomorrow evening but just so I yeah but
you should get you you will get these
titles though because Karen Davis puts
that out to you separately so you should
have that
now yeah you should have it yes I miss
my assistant
okay well thank you very much we are
nothing else for the good of the order
we're adjourned thank
you from my old K days